Where's the music?
There's the music.
Welcome back!
Hello everybody!
Welcome to...
Welcome back.
To Metal Gear Solid 2!
Hello,
hello.
One second, my controller is...
under some cables.
Okay.
I have like a very strange setup here because I have my GameCube...
and then also my PS2.
So it's like...
All these things that I kind of haphazardly set up.
I was like...
I'm lazy.
I don't feel like making it.
All the wires are kind of everywhere.
Don't worry about it!
Say it, boss.
For old times sake.
Kept you waiting, huh?
Yay!
How's my chair?
Actually...
It was an easier fix than I thought.
But I still don't know how it came undone.
Very strange.
For those who don't know, I did a hand cam stream yesterday.
And my chair broke on stream.
And I don't know how it did that.
There's no bolt missing or anything.
No nuts around.
I don't know.
It's very weird.
She said the thing!
Welcome to the membership!
Thanks for the five gifted!
You guys, I will be getting new emotes.
I gave a little bit of a preview.
In...
The members tab.
Community tab.
And some in pre-chat too.
Yeah!
Yippee!
It's actually two different artists.
So I'm going to...
Because I separated them.
One of them is already done.
But I'm going to wait for the other artist as well.
So that I can release them all together.
So...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got into MGS because of you.
What you do to me.
I'm just spreading the good word.
I'm spreading the good word.
Of Metal Gear.
Yeah!
Chair sabotage by Lalilulelo.
So true.
So true!
Finally I'm green!
Thank you!
Hello Mint!
Hello, hello, hello!
Do you have a favorite voice line in MGS2?
Hmm...
That...
Is tough.
I think honestly...
It's any of Raiden's internal monologues.
I think yeah.
What a weirdo.
I love that one.
I love...
What an egotistical woman.
I love that one.
You're a real egotistical woman.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thanks for the five gifted!
I love...
Infinite ammo.
Oh my gosh, what he points to it.
Let me also...
I will post my breathing.
If Mint's chair is broken, we shall become her chair.
Dibs on the footrest.
Stop!
TV table tray!
Thanks for the ten gifted!
Thank you so much!
Not even a poster.
Oh my gosh, yes.
I love when...
There's too many iconic things.
But I think what I quote the most is literally...
Raiden's internal monologues.
Which maybe are not the more iconic things from the game.
You know, you have stuff like dud.
And...
And we've managed to avoid drowning, you know.
Get real.
It's just too much.
It's but...
I quote those all the time.
You got me into MGS and it's so much fun.
Thanks Vise.
Of course!
Thank you Shy Guy.
Let's see.
Okay.
Please no spoilers in the chat.
Not for me, but for anyone who may be joining us and...
watching MGS for the first time.
Thank you!
Replace spend message.
Sorry again about the time change.
If you're watching the VOD...
Hello!
Thanks for watching the VOD!
But if you're here, thank you so much.
I'm so sorry that I had to change it.
I did a little whoopsie in my brain with my schedule.
And kind of had to adjust a little bit.
Do it yourself!
Is my fave.
Get a Herman Miller then name it Master Miller.
But aren't Herman Miller's like super duper expensive, right?
Do we still hide the spoilers with smiley faces?
Yes!
If you wouldn't mind, you know.
I'll do my best as well.
Again, I know we get a little bit excited.
But um... yeah.
Early in the day is...
earlier time is more convenient for me.
Yippee!
Yeah, I know sometimes it'll be more convenient for some people.
And it was like kinda last month.
That I had to change the time.
So I'm so sorry!
No, that is not Solid Snake.
Oh my gosh, yes!
That's so good too.
But um...
Mmm, mmm, mmm.
Use ones for cheap when office is remodeled.
Oh!
Are they that nice though?
Like are they that comfy?
I actually really like my chair.
I've had it for several years now.
Hugo!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
MGS on my birthday!
Can I get a happy birthday minto?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Jay Frosty!
Happy birthday!
If anyone can justify an expensive chair, a successful full-time streamer with Backpenta.
Why are you calling me out?
Oh my gosh.
I don't have my good contacts in.
So it's hard to see sometimes.
Miss Dayz?
Miss Tyze!
Thanks for three months.
Master Miller chair one.
It's writing a message about... Oh my gosh, I read that as MGS.
A message about the time someone mentioned Herman Miller.
Get it?
It is life-changing.
I got one for $400 from Second Hand Distro.
Because offices, I'm using this to put the shillet.
Oh.
Treat yourself, dummy!
You guys, I almost...
I tried to treat myself today.
There was a bubble tea place that opened near my maid cafe and I was like, I'm gonna go get bubble tea!
I was gonna treat myself.
And it wasn't open yet.
It wasn't open yet.
I didn't get it.
It said I got cake.
It said I went to the store and I was like, fine.
I'll just go get cake.
And I ate one bite of it.
And then I put it in my fridge.
Because that's what I do.
I'm gonna eat one bite of it and then put it back in my fridge.
Brick!
A Minto gear solid stream on my birthday!
It's the perfect present.
How did you know?
Oh my gosh!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Brick!
Happy birthday!
Okay, Saku.
I'll be on the lookout for you sending me the place that you got your chair.
I'll look into them.
My chair is perfectly fine though.
It's hard to justify dropping that much money.
Well, I say perfectly fine.
It broke last night.
But I think it's okay now.
You know?
But then there's also me who's just like, gosh.
I'll waste money.
I spend my money on things that I don't need sometimes.
Like Metal Gear merch.
But also, I'll be like, what if I just upgrade my computer and get a new graphics card?
Because I want my PC to be all white and aesthetic.
When my graphics card is perfectly fine.
But also, I use my graphics card every day.
So like, what if I also, what if I just, you know...
Spray paint it?
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
My contacts are so bad today.
Well...
Sounds like a business expense to me.
You're so right though.
And then I was also looking at the height.
They have like the PC cases that have...
that have like the little screen on them.
And I was like, I could put something on that.
What could I put on that?
Oh my gosh.
Nexy!
Thank you.
Thank you, Master Miller.
I summoned a loose screw for Minto to buy chairs.
Yeah.
Going to get a doki case.
It's too yellow.
Right now...
Right now... Wait, I just realized some of my lights aren't on.
Right now my setup is pink and blue.
But also, I have the Corsair fans.
But they're off-colored.
I don't think they're... If I set it to red or pink, it's turns more like orange.
Makes me so sad.
Get doki to play Metal Gear to see her reaction.
I don't know if she would like Metal Gear.
Mint case.
Hmm...
Have I played Metal Gear Rising Revengeance on stream?
Not yet!
I'll play it eventually.
Once we get through the series.
Too much cutscene for her small bird brain.
You think?
MGS is too much thinking.
You guys are roasting her!
Wow!
No, but I do think maybe...
I don't know.
She played, what, Sandland?
But she doesn't typically do, like, games that...
are so long.
You know what I mean?
She might like Five.
I think she would like to play Five, probably, right?
Hmm...
It's a thinker man's game.
Which MGS is your least favorite?
Five.
But only...
Only cause of...
the story.
The gameplay is top tier.
Even a pigeon would have a better time...
Five for the writing, yeah.
But Five for the gameplay is my favorite.
The gameplay is 10 out of 10.
So great.
Not because of Kiefer.
He's fine.
I played Five first.
I think it'd be a good intro.
Oh...
Wait...
Are you...
Are you being sarcastic?
How can you play Five before you play Peace Walker?
I don't understand.
But...
Going back to the Kiefer Sutherland thing...
I actually don't mind him voicing...
Venom.
Because...
I think if I heard...
If I heard David Hayter be so brooding and sad, I might be like...
I can't... I can't deal with this.
Love how you scared Doki with Freddy the Scream.
Truly a cinema moment.
I feel like Metal Gear...
I'm guessing you like bipedal war machines in a good way.
Might I recommend Titanfall 2?
I do like...
I do...
I do... I do...
I do like Machine.
Yes.
That reminds me...
I was...
was going through some of my stuff from Ofgai.
I got a big old package and it's kind of just been sitting in, like, the box that got sent to me.
And there were some things in there that...
I didn't even see before they were sent out.
Like someone...
I'm going to say your Twitter name because that's what you wrote on it.
Angel Milk42, thank you for the iCots book, if you're watching.
And someone gifted me the Phantom Pain hand, and then a steelbook case of the Phantom Pain.
So thank you!
10,000% seriousness?
Noooo!
Lorem, weirdness hooked my brain.
I knew the vague snake story because friends are obsessed.
Okay.
I shut up.
We'll ride in.
Noooo!
You don't even know who Ocelot is!
You don't even know who Miller is!
You don't even know who Chico is!
You don't even know who Paz is!
You don't even know who Snake is!
There's no reason to play 5 before you play anything else!
You don't know what's going on!
How could you know what's going on?
How could you know?
How could you know what's happening?
You would just go in, you'd be like so confused.
If you didn't even play Ground Zeroes...
Okay, at least play Ground Zeroes.
But then you're still just like...
I don't even know what Mother Base is.
I don't know what MSF is.
I don't know who Chico is.
I don't know who Paz is.
I don't know why...
Why should I care about Paz blowing up?
Don't play 5 first!
First!
God!
There's my aneurysm.
Oh my gosh, I'm starting to see black.
Hold on.
What did you say, Dogstrings?
I'm going to Ani-Revo this year?
I was hyped to hear you were joining Doki for a bit.
Yeah!
Doing our concert together.
We gotta start with Peace Walker.
Peace Walker, GZ, Peace Wa...
Oh, wait.
Peace Walker, GZ, and Peace...
Wait, and Peace Wa...
You mean Pantopage?
No.
Make up MGS5.
Yes.
But then you can't play Peace Walker without playing 3.
You see the problem here?
Then you have to...
You can't play 3 without playing 1 or 2.
You don't have to.
You don't know who Ocelot is.
You don't know anything about the Patriots.
You don't know anything.
You don't know...
Well, I guess you learned about the Philosopher's Legacy.
Wait, did they mention the Philosopher's Legacy in this game?
I'm trying not to talk about spoilers.
But you don't know anything!
You don't know anything!
You have to start at the beginning!
Oh no, she's nerding out.
Calm down, Min...
I'm sorry.
They don't mention in this game.
Okay.
But...
There's the spoilers at the end of the game.
The little call with...
With...
About...
About the...
Wait for Delta.
The best way to get into Metal Gear.
Truly though, I think Delta will get so many people playing Metal Gear for the first time.
I'm quite excited about it.
But I'm also just like...
Ocelot.
You just...
You just won't understand!
Gotta start at Snatchers or Psychonauts.
Okay.
I am done talking about Metal Gear for so long.
You gotta start at MGS by watching a playthrough.
Oh, sure!
Thank you for the birthday gift!
Thank you so much!
Which MGS game did you play first hand?
Oh, Metal Gear...
Oh, sorry.
Which MGS?
Of course!
I started at Metal Gear Solid 1!
What are you talking about?
Now, if you would ask me which Metal Gear I started at, that's a different story.
But you specifically said, which MGS did you start at?
And MGS Metal Gear Solid is its own thing.
And then Metal Gear Rising.
That's MGR.
You know some...
It's...
It's like...
You know...
It's the specifics.
The specifics matter.
Right?
Yeah.
Semantics.
Yep.
They're important.
What if I play Phantom Pain and nothing else?
What a nerd!
But yeah.
Let's see.
Last time we left off, we were about to defuse some bombs.
We got our smelly detector.
Hold on.
I'm holding it.
I'm putting it over chat.
P.U.
We're, uhm...
Gonna defuse the bombs and, yeah.
We met Plissken.
I took out my earbuds to avoid rage spoilers.
No!
I don't think I spoil......
Oh.
I don't think I spoiled anything.
I just said that you need to know this, to know that, to know this, to know that.
Today is my birthday!
Can you sing me happy birthday?
Also, can't wait to see you.
Otaku-tan!
Thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
Nuts on fire!
Happy birthday to you!
I spoiled a little bit?
Oh, I mentioned pause.
Oh.
Yeah, okay.
That was my bad.
That was a ground zero spoiler.
My bad.
My bad, my bad, my bad, my bad.
But um...
You mentioned so much...
No, I didn't!
We are not so...
Ah, this is my cat!
She's so cute!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Last night, I was doing my face mask and I walk into my bedroom and both of my cats are laying where I'm supposed to lay.
They're like right underneath my pillow.
And it's the first time!
Usually, Paz sleeps at my feet.
But this was the first time!
This was the first time!
She laid close to my head!
I was so happy.
And then this morning, I went to feed her and she was laying down and she stood up and she stretched and she let out the nastiest fart.
You guys, I think I have to rename her to Johnny.
Real.
I think I have to rename her to Johnny.
I really need to take her to the vet for her.
I think she has I think she has IBS or something.
I think she has a like a real problem.
Sometimes she gets like drippy and just like drips poop everywhere.
I'm constantly having to clean.
She hasn't in a while though.
But I really need to take her to the vet.
But I was so focused on Butaro.
I hadn't been able to take her.
I was like focusing on him first.
I'm just constantly going to the vet over and over and over again.
Nah.
Not the stinky duo.
She's like legitimately stinky.
Ripped the people eating while walking the street.
I'm so sorry.
But yeah, Butaro is eating better.
He is.
But he's like, I think he has like food and anxiety now.
Because he was hungry for so long because he wasn't able to eat.
But now he's like constantly, constantly constantly begging for food.
So I'm constantly, constantly, constantly having to feed him.
But he eats it up!
He eats it up!
So uh...
But he's been eating a lot.
And gaining weight.
So I'm happy about that.
And he hasn't been throwing up.
But it's been pretty good.
All things considered.
Yeah.
Okay, it's been a half hour.
I'm loading the game.
Let me know how the audio is and everything too.
This one.
I wonder where it's going to put us.
Stinky.
Where am I?
What?
Okay, hold on.
I have to remember how to play the game.
Okay.
Raiden's behind looks very good here!
Wowee!
Oh my goodness!
Look at that!
My lumps!
My lovely lady lumps!
Wow!
Uh...
There we go.
Wowee!
Okay.
Oh, this is where Snake went.
Oh my gosh.
That scared the badonkas out of me.
Blizz can win that way!
Oh my gosh!
Who am I talking about?
So a guy comes down this way?
What am I hearing?
I'm hearing a buzzing sound.
No!
It's not Solid Snake!
Sorry!
I totally... You know how...
Okay, so sorry.
I was reading some fan theories online that said that...
That maybe...
Blizzkin is Solid Snake, but I think it's totally BS.
Yeah, Snake died.
It's really sad.
Shoot!
Wait.
Okay, okay.
Just got here from my favorite soap opera.
Starting riding in rows.
Why am I forgetting everything on how to play this game again?
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Where did that guy go anyway?
Do you think he'll see me right here?
I know, I know.
I gotta find the nerd.
I think there's this guy and then there's also...
Do you guys hear that buzzing?
Or is it just me?
Do you guys hear a buzzing or is it just...
Oh, it's driving me insane.
Oh, it's the bugs at the doorway!
Oh my gosh.
They're driving me actually insane.
Come on, guy.
Come back, please.
Oh, here he comes.
Here he comes.
I'm too scared.
I'm too...
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
Where is he?
I'm too scared to move.
I gotta get back into it.
Knock on the wall.
I'm scared.
Sorry.
I'm gonna take a second to get used to it.
I don't know why I'm feeling so strange about the game all of a sudden.
I feel like I'm a baby.
Like I've just been thrown into something and I don't even know what I'm doing.
I don't know why I'm feeling so uncomfortable.
Uncomfortable, I think is the right word.
I'm feeling uncomfortable.
I don't know why.
Hello?
Please come back.
You're taking...
I'm sick of these bugs.
I just wanna get used to the game, but you're making me uncomfortable.
You're becoming too much like Raiden.
Where is he?
Wait.
I think he's coming.
I hear him.
Hello?
My hands are cramping.
Okay.
Goodnight.
I think there's a guy...
Isn't there a guy in here?
Where's the nerd at?
No, I'm still...
I'm still hearing the... I don't hear the buzzing anymore.
Huh.
I don't hear it when I pause.
Weird.
Bottom right?
Down here?
No.
Where's the nerd?
Oh, shut up!
I hate you guys!
Is he the guy that was wandering this room?
Oh!
No, no, no.
Oh my god.
I saw it though.
Huh.
There we go.
Alright, come on.
Uh, there we go.
Ahhh!
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know why I'm feeling so weird!
Anxious.
Anxious, anxious.
So we have this.
This is finding our stinky... stinkiness.
Do you have anything for me?
Any lockers in here?
Hmm.
Take that though.
Could I stick him...
in here?
I was like, who else do I hear asleep?
Let me in!
Okay!
The toilet!
Can we put him in there?
Eh, it's fine.
We'll just leave.
I hear a buzzing.
Okay.
First bomb!
Um...
It is up here.
Yay!
Her big voice!
Anything wrong?
Maybe.
Plissken's reported other locations too.
And none of them are effective demolition points.
What do you mean?
It means that they wouldn't be the best places to choose if you wanted to destroy this place.
Are you saying they don't plan on blowing the shell up?
Wiggle, wiggle.
It certainly seems that way.
So far we haven't seen anything but a waste of good explosives.
Unless, of course, we're missing something.
A trap?
Whatever.
There's something going on.
Right.
Whatever.
Alright, let's head back to this place.
Whatever!
Is there a way for us to send you fan letter?
If we do, is there a certain letter writing protocol we should follow?
Um...
I don't really have a place to send fan letters, unfortunately.
I appreciate you...
And it's gone.
I appreciate you wanting to.
Um...
And if you ever...
If I ever do have a way for you to send fan letters, you can...
It's not like, you know...
We can just ramble on about random stuff we're doing.
Yeah, you can always just...
It doesn't have to be like a set whatever.
It can just be something.
Hello?
Oh, there it is.
Shoot.
There we go.
La la la la la.
Fortune was there.
That's where the dud happened.
The dud.
Can you receive psychic messages?
Or Ouija board summonings?
I try to ignore the Ouija board stuff.
Cause um...
Where is it here?
I don't remember actually.
I hear it like right here.
I don't remember.
I don't remember where it's at.
Where does that guy go?
Does he come through here?
He's not gonna hear me.
I don't think it's in here, is it?
No, it can't be in the locker.
Oh, let's put this guy in the locker though.
Come here.
Come here, Bobby.
Come on, come on, come on.
Oh wait.
I might have to wait.
I might have to loop around again.
If you would stop snoring so loudly.
Maybe.
Good night, sweet prince.
There's another one for this guy too.
Where is he?
Where is the guy?
Oh shoot.
Oh, he's coming this way.
We'll get him.
We'll get him once he starts walking away.
There we go.
Good night, little babies.
What do you got for me?
I'll take that.
Good night, little babies.
Good night, boys.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait.
I can't remember where this one is though.
And now they go into the locker.
And they don't wake up.
Good night.
Okay, perfect.
One for each guy.
Where was it again?
It stinks in here.
Not in here.
I hear it.
Or I heard it.
This area is so vague.
This one is so sneaky.
Because it's smelly everywhere but then you hear it here.
It's so confusing.
Why are you so sneaky?
I can't remember at all where it is.
Is it in the doorway?
Hello?
Do I need to crawl?
Did they just leave all the blood and everything?
Why can I hear it?
Maybe it's on the other side.
But I don't hear...
Oh, I heard it.
Beep.
What the...
Crawl on the ground like a baby?
Should I cry like a baby too?
Thank you so much for the 30 gifts.
Okay, I'm annoying myself.
I'm even annoying myself.
Guys!
I know you're gonna say no ALP.
Could I get a hint?
I don't remember at all where it is.
I don't remember at all.
Those doors closed.
Oh my god!
Thanks for the ALP.
Laugh.
Yeah.
Yippee!
Alright.
Onward we go.
Uh...
Where else do we need to go?
Hold on, I'm gonna call.
Please can't!
Me too!
This one was in a spot so narrow I had to crawl in to get at it.
Oh, we're gonna have to do that too later on.
Stillman!
Where do I go?
Leah!
Riding reporting.
The C4 in Strut B has been disposed of.
Hello!
The wall containing the transformer panel was set to blow.
You're taking too much time.
You should work a little faster.
Sorry.
There's no time riding.
I've got my hands full here so it doesn't look like I can help you.
Okay, nobody asked you.
It's in your hands.
Well done.
It looks like there are no more bombs in that strut.
Wait, what?
Now, head for the other struts.
Huh?
Riding with his gaming posture.
Run.
I love it.
Lali... lu...
Wait.
Lalialulelo.
Head to the other struts.
Oh.
No!
I just missed.
Oh.
Hello.
Go.
Good night.
Come back here so I can loot you.
Please.
Thank you.
Okay.
Lalialulelo.
M9 is such a good gun.
I know.
Oh my gosh.
It's just so nice.
It's just so nice having it.
Though I wish I had a suppressor on.
Hello?
You little cheesy.
Give me something.
Give me a present.
There we go.
I think they meant the real M9.
This is the real M9.
What are you talking about?
Is it stinky in here or...
Is it you guys?
Oh my god.
There's somebody there.
No.
Get inside.
Get inside Raiden.
Raiden, close the door.
Raiden, close the door!
Oh god.
Okay.
Never mind.
Gosh, Raiden.
You scared me.
Oh, I see smelly.
I see smelly.
It's upstairs, I think?
Ah.
Oh, I think I have to go...
How do I get over to that area?
Jump.
What?
How did I...
There's somebody there.
No, there's not.
Just a...
Where's my box?
Where is my box?
Hello?
Wait.
I forgot.
I picked it up.
It's a...
A snake.
Yeah, I never got the box.
How did he see me?
This guy has eyes of a hawk.
For real.
Jump.
Oh my god.
He's the one that got me last time too.
So scared of him.
I'm so scared of this guy.
Okay.
Where do I go?
This way?
Okay, it's this room.
Okay, I know this room.
Oh my gosh.
Is there a locker in here?
Stuff you're in?
So I can take my time?
If I shoot that...
The guy in the other room will probably hear.
I think.
Is there a locker in here?
No, that's not a locker.
A box!
You guys say no Alp.
You guys say no Alp there.
Is the Alp right there?
I think I might have to take him out, you guys.
I think...
Oh, I have to tranquilize him as well.
You're right.
Okay, let's get that.
I think if I do it right here...
Will he see me?
Please don't see me.
Oh!
Dang it, he doesn't go far enough.
It's okay.
We'll just have to be speedy fast about it.
Now I have to remember...
how I did this before.
Alright, ride in.
Crawl.
Crawl this way.
Ride in.
I said we need to be speedy.
Come on.
Okay.
Crawl this way.
He's waking up.
No he's not!
This way.
Crawl.
Will he be able to see me?
Nice.
Which way do I go?
Oh shoot, I don't remember.
I don't...
What?
What do you want?
No one's going to leave a bomb...
in a place that easy to reach.
It would be more worthwhile to search convoluted areas...
that can't be reached simply by walking.
I'm working on it!
Stillman, please!
Let me do my job!
God.
I'm working on my art!
How do I get through again?
It's like over there.
I don't remember where it is.
I just...
I just want to say that you were the cutest.
Stop it!
I'm too slow.
I know!
He's got...
twosies.
Sleep.
I really want to take out this other guy so I can freely roll.
Actually, I don't really just want to shoot him.
I want to take him out in general.
But I'm too good of a person.
It's right there, isn't it?
It's like right there.
I think.
Yeah, I see it!
I literally see it!
Can I go through here?
No.
Wait, I think I can go through right here.
There it is!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Can I go on top of this?
Yeah.
Okay.
And we get our box!
Yippee!
Wait, can I go through here?
Nope.
Okay, hold on.
I'm figuring it out.
I'm figuring it out!
How do I...
How do I get over there?
Um...
Eh...
It's right...
Come on, Raiden.
Just use your hands.
Raiden, just...
Raiden, just use your hands.
Raiden, please.
Oh my gosh.
It's right there!
How do I get through?
Raiden.
Raiden!
Call Plissken?
What's he got to say?
Does he know this place?
I mean...
Raiden, don't get yourself worked up.
I'm worked up!
It's safer to take out the enemy first, then look for the bomb.
Don't even think about searching for the bomb while looking over your shoulder for the enemy.
Knock them unconscious or take them out altogether first.
He's giving me permission!
He's giving me permission to take them out.
I mean...
It's Plissken's advice.
Who am I to...
Go against Plissken?
Extreme violence.
I just want to take out the camera.
I feel better without it.
I also don't remember how to get through.
Is it right here?
No.
Can I get a hint?
Why are these bombs always such a pain in my side?
It's right there!
Red pipe.
I was just over there, though.
Ask Fat Manion.
Wait, what do you mean, red pipe?
Red pipe is the hint-o.
Minto.
Little Minto Hinto.
I'm too paranoid about this guy.
Hey, stay down!
Or you'll be staying down forever.
I could take him out and then hide in the box.
The guy will never know.
Well, he'll hear.
He will hear.
Red pipe.
This one.
Wait, do I crawl through here?
I did it.
A little lower.
There we go.
Stinky averted.
This is Raiden.
The C4 found in Strut A has been frozen and disposed of.
How many more do I have?
Wow.
Explosives were planted in the pump room on the first floor.
Yeah, crazy.
This is all wrong.
This is something only an amateur would do.
What do you mean?
All the bombs that have been found so far don't appear to be in the right kind of locations.
They're distraction bombs.
Probably.
Even Fat Man can make mistakes, right?
No, no.
There's something else going on here.
Get a move on with the disposal, right?
I've got a bad feeling about this.
Do you think it's a trap?
I don't know.
But I'm going to tell Plissken to watch his back too.
Just hurry.
Wait, where's the next one?
Hold on.
Stillman.
Will you consider streaming Unmetal?
I've actually thought about it.
I think I got it.
I don't remember.
But yeah, I would consider streaming it.
No worries asking.
Nebula, thanks for the gift.
Well done.
It looks like there are no more bombs in that strut.
Now, head for the other struts.
The other struts.
Okay.
Plissken, what are you doing?
Me too!
Okay.
Is this guy still...
Yeah, we're still good.
Let's get out of here.
Go to the next strut.
Good night, little man.
You can see all the darts in his head.
Oh my god!
He's going to look like a porcupine by the end.
Pinhead.
Who you calling Pinhead?
Best acupuncture ever.
Real.
This one has some guys, don't it?
Oh, that's coolant.
That's coolant.
Let's not get caught by the...
Is he going to come up on this end?
Oh my gosh.
Hi!
Where is he?
Where'd he go?
There he is.
Uh... uh...
Dang it.
I can't shoot it.
Because I'll hear it.
I think he'll... I think he'll...
I think he'll panic.
I should reach if I spray long enough.
The wind will carry it.
The wind will carry it all the way.
No, I can't do it.
It's no good.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, come on!
There we go.
And uh...
Can I...
Oh, come on!
I always...
We were right there.
Oh my god, please!
Shoot!
There we go.
Sometimes that happens to me.
Where I...
try to...
hit it and it...
doesn't decide to go.
Rookie mistake.
I know.
Perfect time for some pull-ups.
I'm already...
You know what?
I think I'll top off my life...
and we'll grab this.
Nice.
Let's go look for...
some more stinky.
What was this?
Oh, oh no.
No, wait.
I hate this area.
Shoot.
No, I hate this room.
What card do I have?
Oh, just level one.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
I don't even have...
I don't even have the nerd here.
Nothing here.
Permission to backseat?
Granted.
Nothing here.
Backseating.
Permission granted.
Is he gonna come back?
I need the nerd.
No help.
I didn't ask you.
Actually, what if I...
Hold on.
Backseat tip.
Don't get spotted.
This guy is still out.
Not gonna lie.
I just ran out here.
Completely forgot about him.
I didn't even think about this guy.
He was not even on my radar.
I'm the worst.
I'm the worst at sneaking.
He's gonna get caught.
Oh my god.
What the?
How did you not get caught?
How did you not get put to sleep?
Now I know the smell is...
Yeah.
I know where it's at.
Gosh.
Okay.
This room is such a pain.
Oh my god.
This room is such a pain in the neck.
I have to...
Wait.
He's gonna say...
Hey.
Why aren't you reporting?
Why aren't you reporting in the room?
Hey.
Somebody go check it out.
That's what's gonna happen.
Oh my gosh.
I hate this room.
I hate this room so much.
They don't see me just...
aiming my gun everywhere right now.
This
room.
I hate this room.
Can I take out his...
But I think I'm gonna get...
Oh wait.
I have to take out the other guy.
Oh gosh.
I wish I took out the other guy.
Because then I could run around and take out their...
Get their...
Their radios.
You can just chaff radio.
Wait.
Really?
So if I chaff it...
while they try to communicate...
You can?
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I gotta get this guy.
Dig in.
Yeah.
This is good actually.
Get him.
Get his ass.
There we go.
Okay.
And I'm gonna chaff...
I think that's everybody in here.
Is that everybody in here?
Can I still take out their radios?
I don't know that.
Oh it did.
It did.
It worked.
Just so when the chaff is over...
Oh wait.
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Where...
Oh they're over here.
Over here.
It's okay.
Ah, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit!
No, no, no!
Chop, chop, chop!
Noooo!!!
What?!
You guys lied to me.
You guys lied to me, you guys lied to me, you guys lied to me.
You all lied to me!
You lie!
You lied to me, you!
I'll never forgive you, I'll never, I'll never ever, I'll never forgive you guys.
Guys, I'll never forgive you.
I'll never forgive you.
I'll never forgive you!
I need to actually calm down.
I'm so... I'm so mad at you guys!
Oh my god, I'm so mad at you guys.
You guys, I had that room clean.
I had that room clean!
It was so clean and that...
It was so clean.
It was so clean!
Oh gosh, I was doing so well.
You were doing it right but the chaff wore off.
No, no!
It was still up!
It was still up while it called!
I'm so mad.
Hold on, I gotta take a walk.
Wait, I was already paused.
I gotta take a walk!
I'm back.
I'm convinced that the Patriots were in my chat and were...
So it wasn't you guys, it was the Patriots.
Don't worry.
I believe you.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I'm gonna have to go in there.
But for now, we're not gonna go in there.
Screw that room.
I'm gonna take out this guy up there.
Can I...
Oh wait.
Wrong gun.
Can I hit him from here?
Can I get his tiny little peeny head?
Teeny tiny head?
What am I doing?
Sniper Minto at it again.
Oh, who's calling me?
Be careful.
There are claymore mines around there.
Who is this?
Stealth-equipped claymore mines.
Invisible to the naked eye.
Oh.
Use the mine detector.
Identify yourself.
Just call me Deep Throat.
Oh my god.
Deep Throat?
You mean from Shadow Moses?
From Shadow Moses!
Mr. X then.
Mr. X now, is it?
Why would it matter if I called you Deep Throat?
Never mind about that.
Okay.
Why did you contact me?
Let's just say I'm one of your fans.
Stop.
You can't use his line too.
Oh.
Hello?
Colonel, someone calling himself Mr. X just contacted me.
Call him by his name, right?
And it's Deep Throat.
And whoever it was, it wasn't a burst transmission.
The transmission was sent from within the big shell.
He called himself Deep Throat at first.
Yeah.
Do you think I caught that part too?
But the possibility of it being true is none.
It's Gray Fox.
Gray Fox.
No!
Gray Fox!
No, it's not!
Not in my heart.
Extreme caution.
Do I have a mind detector?
I don't even have a mind detector.
Oh wait, I have thermal goggles.
Oh gosh.
Oh my god.
Wait, I have a question.
Actually I don't know if I can trust you guys.
I have a question.
If I crawl... wait, it's only in 5, right?
That if I crawl, it blows up?
Oh, thank goodness.
My eyes!
You know what?
Screw it.
I'm just gonna crawl.
And I'll go this way.
I'll go this way.
Keep going.
Wait.
Okay.
My eyes!
Okay, and then there's a bomb in here.
Is this also the room that I hate?
No, I think that's the middle one.
Or is it this one?
A parcel room.
This one... I
think this room was pretty okay.
I don't remember.
I don't remember where the bomb... I know there's two guys.
Right?
It's just the two?
Nothing here.
Status report.
I gotta shoot his butt.
Okay, hold on.
Can he see me?
No.
Once he goes back, I'm gonna try and get this guy out first.
The boxes!
I was too slow.
Oh, shoot.
Where does he come from?
I think he's gonna see me.
He's yawnin'.
He's stretchin'.
The other guy's asleep!
Hey, hey.
Freeze.
Oh my god.
You know what?
I'm not... I'm not doing this again.
Sorry.
I'm a murderer now.
This is... this is me now.
I'm a murderer.
I'm a murderer!
Sorry, mister.
Oh.
Stun grenade.
You enjoy all the killing.
Is that a radio?
Or is that just him?
I think he's just got a thick butt.
Sorry.
Okay.
Sorry, buddy.
Anyway.
Time to find a bomb.
Oh.
My bad.
Wrong thing.
What?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I shot the radio!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Um.
Maybe they won't come.
Damn it.
Uh-oh.
Hold on.
Oh.
Not so fast, huh?
realizing
so fast.
What do you mean that wasn't the radio?
I thought he just had a fat ass.
That guy never even sent in a status report.
That guy never even lifted his radio even once.
That guy never even gave two flips about his radio.
And now suddenly you care about the status report.
Why are you telling me this now?
And I'm facing the wall.
Do you think I'm safe?
I can't see anything.
I think I can get the nerd at least.
There we go.
This game terrifies me.
It's too advanced for my P-Brain.
It's too advanced for my P-Brain, for real.
Goodness gracious.
Wait, did they not... did they only replace the one guy?
I think they only replaced the one guy.
They didn't notice the other one?
You understand how smart you are?
Stay strong, Ghost Maid.
Thank you.
Nothing here.
Wait, I'm scared of taking him out though.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
There's somebody there.
No.
Nobody here.
I'm just going to box it.
Oh wait, he's going to see the other dead guy!
Oh, never mind.
He doesn't care.
These guys!
These guys... These guys are ridiculous, I swear.
They're so silly.
I love... I love these Gerlukovich soldiers.
They're so dumb.
Okay, you know what?
I'm just gonna try and find the bomb.
Nothing here... I wanna get that cardboard box, though.
If I shoot his radio, and then... will he notice?
Let's go upstairs.
Nothing... Where's this lead to?
Hold on, I don't wanna go out yet.
I think he'll hear.
If I just... take him out...
I'm on the right place, right?
Yeah, there's a bomb in here.
Somewhere.
Ask Plissken.
What does Plissken gotta say?
That guy's so smart.
He's so smart!
He's so smart.
Smart guy.
You know what?
Do I go downstairs?
I can't remember where it's at.
Come on, Raiden.
Back...
Raiden.
Is it downstairs?
Nothing here...
No, but this is where the... Oh, there's the mine detector!
No, I can't go through there yet.
And I can't go through there yet.
I guess we go upstairs?
When you know, but you don't want to help.
It's these little things though, like these details I forget so much, you know?
Wait, um...
No...
I thought I remembered, but I don't.
I thought I remembered, but I do not.
Nothing here...
I don't remember.
The heliport.
This is...
Another place.
Wait...
We're not about to experience this part, are we?
Do a Frogbert codec call.
What do you mean by that?
I've taken care of that annoying fly.
What's the situation over there?
Buzzing.
I saw a man dressed like a ninja just now.
Mmm!
Ninja?
It's the only way to describe it.
A kind of cyborg ninja, complete with a sword.
What?
Are you hiding something from me?
Olga, are you sure it wasn't an Arsenal Tengu?
Arsenal Tengu?
Don't be a fool.
Think I wouldn't know the difference?
I've never seen field gear like that, ever.
Alright, we'll intensify patrols.
Anything else?
Actually, one more thing.
You'll find it hard to believe, though.
What's that?
I saw a man hiding under a cardboard box.
Where?
It wasn't me.
So you believe me this time.
What the hell is an Arsenal Tengu?
Like I know what a Tengu is.
Oh my gosh.
You must be one of Dead Cell.
Of course not.
What a thing to say.
Drop your gun.
Olga, so I saw...
Oh!
Where'd she go?
She did a flip.
She's so cool.
I saw a female soldier.
Russian.
Must be Olga Gerlukovich.
How do you know?
Unlike you, I've been briefed.
She's not a Dead Cell?
No.
She commands a Russian private army.
What's that supposed to mean?
They must be the ones patrolling the Big Shell.
That's right.
She's led the group ever since her old man, Colonel Gerlukovich, died.
Watch yourself with her.
She's a tough one.
No.
What's that supposed to mean?
So aggressive.
Oh, there are guys here.
Let's have our other gun out.
Can they see me here?
Oh, there's two of them.
Where's the other guy?
Hello?
I'm a natural.
Wait, do these guys have radios?
I'm so paranoid.
I'm so paranoid of radios.
I think it usually happens like immediately though, right?
Oh, can I flip you?
Oh, wait.
Is this it?
Oh, that's it.
Is it?
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
This is it.
No.
Sorry.
My bad.
This is it.
Nope.
Where is the radio?
Is this it?
Sorry.
Sorry, mister.
I was just trying to find a radio.
Sorry.
Um...
Uh...
We gotta hide the body.
We gotta get rid of the body.
They won't notice.
They won't care about the blood.
We gotta get rid...
We gotta throw them into the ocean.
We gotta get rid of...
We gotta get rid of the body.
I didn't... I didn't...
I thought...
There has to be a way to flip them over?
I don't know how.
Oh, dang it.
Is there a way to flip them over?
Or...
You know...
Dang.
This whole ship is stinky.
I mean...
This whole...
Aircraft is stinky.
Whatever.
Okay.
Probably will have to lay down.
I don't hear anything.
This smells like ship.
Beep.
Oh, there it is.
Can I reach?
Hold on.
Let's get in closer.
Oh.
There we go.
I can't reach?
Just kidding.
There...
That should be good.
That should reach it?
Perfect!
Alright.
That takes care of that.
Did you have anything for me?
I think I saw that there's a guy over here.
Right here.
Isn't there?
Yeah.
Let's ignore him.
And...
Run away.
We don't need to talk to that guy.
We can...
Ignore him.
And run away.
We can just...
Ignore him.
Oh.
Yes?
Yeah.
I didn't hear the gun.
Jack.
Do you remember the day we met?
I'm kind of busy right now, Rose.
Yeah.
Keep going.
I do remember.
It was right after I transferred to New York.
There are all these tourists around you.
In front of the federal hall.
Oh my gosh.
It's starting.
A group of middle-aged Japanese ladies came up and asked me which building it was that King Kong was climbing in the movie.
I said it was probably the Chrysler building.
And then you, um, actually me.
And then you showed up and started mouthing off.
You were like, no, it's the Empire State.
Yeah.
Dummy.
Stupid woman.
It's the Empire State Building.
We started arguing and I forgot all about the tourists.
I was insisting that I was right and you were doing the same.
The next thing we knew, the Japanese women had gone away.
Yeah, because I don't want to listen to two people bickering.
To see who had the better recall.
We argued all the way to New York.
We had a battery park.
And for nothing.
Since the museum was closed, we went our separate ways from the museum.
I love this version, though.
And then I found you again by coincidence out in the base corridor.
An amazing coincidence that we were actually working at the same place.
Yeah, coincidence.
It was so beautiful.
Yeah.
I could look down on the Chrysler Building from 120 stories above ground.
I felt overwhelmed.
I didn't care.
I didn't care anymore who was right.
Yeah, I would hope not after that much time.
You watched King Kong in your apartment a bunch of times that night.
Oh, I bet.
Didn't sleep till morning.
If it weren't for that coincidence, we wouldn't be together.
I know.
I'm sorry, Jack.
I'm taking up your time again.
Yeah.
What?
Take care.
No, Rose!
Keep calling me!
Please!
I eat it up!
Oh, my gosh.
Jack, do you remember the day we first met?
Rose, please.
There are bombs.
There are literal bombs.
I am defusing.
I am bomb defusing right now.
Rose!
Am I wrong for kind of liking Rose, Jack?
No!
They're my favorite couple ever.
I love them.
Women.
Yeah, he comes up.
He just comes up.
Can you imagine?
I just imagine her being like, hmm, to these like group of like very unassuming women.
They're just like, oh.
Rose, no comment.
About?
Oh!
I've killed someone.
Jack, it's a battlefield.
My opponents are living, breathing human beings.
This isn't like the VR training.
They have bodies.
They have had lives.
I took all that away from them.
But you've got no choice if you want to survive.
Yeah.
And yet, maybe because of the VR training, I can't help but try and block out that reality.
I killed a person.
It's the only way I can manage to fight.
Jack.
I didn't mean to kill them.
I don't care what it takes.
Just a little bit.
Just as long as you come back alive.
The first two, yes.
But not that last guy.
Do whatever it takes, please.
Just come back in one piece.
In one piece.
Okay.
Um.
Oh, yeah.
I can...
Can you just imagine like these ladies that are just like, oh, sumimasen.
Excuse me.
Do you know which building was King Kong?
And she's just like, hmm.
I'm pretty sure it was the Chrysler building.
And I just see his head whipping around.
He's just like.
Oh.
You stupid woman.
The Chrysler building.
It is the Empire State Building.
You stupid idiot.
Why would you say it's the Chrysler building when everybody knows it's the Empire State Building?
She's like huffing and puffing and she's just like, whoa, man.
She's just like, you don't have to be so rude.
You don't have to be so rude.
And then they're just arguing.
Walking along arguing and just being so angry at each other.
Right.
Stillman is a top notch explosives technician.
Follow his instructions.
Colonel, why are you being so boring?
Gotcha.
I'll look him up.
Hold on a moment.
So your earlier rant about MGS5...
What are you even talking about?
Wait, wait, wait.
It's completely different.
I was right.
Me too!
What?
So the guy didn't notice?
Well done.
It looks like there are no more bombs in that strut.
Now, head for the other struts.
King Kong, watch along.
When?
We have to watch it over and over and over again.
We can't get any sleep, you guys.
Just like them.
Just like my favorite couple.
Is that guy still...
Did they replace him?
Or is he just still dead on the ground?
Let's go over here.
Oh, he's back.
Hold on.
Is he just gone?
They didn't replace him at all?
Nothing here.
I don't think they replaced him.
Back from the dead?
Crazy.
I'm trying to decide if I want to head back to this one and risk it all.
It's kind of annoying because otherwise...
I think this...
Save F for last.
Yeah, I think we'll save it for last.
I'm trying to decide how I want to do it.
But...
Can I get on top of this and go as a box?
I think that's what you can do, right?
Jump up, ride him.
Ask for uppies.
Wait, I can't go this way though.
Oh, it's over here.
That's right.
I know.
I know the way.
What's box 2?
Oh, is this the zone of the Enders 1?
Oh no.
I think...
Where is the zone of the Enders 1?
Have I not gotten to that part yet?
Bye bye.
Uppies from Raiden.
Ran survives a hellish childhood and becomes a functioning adult who mansplains video trivia to random women on the street.
Is that a sniper up there?
Yeah, you know.
That's just Raiden...
things.
Wait, how do I get rid of the sniper?
Go away.
Stop staring, you freak.
I'm trying to wait for the other guy.
But he'll notice, won't he?
Oh, I think I have to... Okay, it's red light, green light.
Green light.
Oh, he's walking away!
He gave up!
And now we can take out your friend.
There we go.
But I am still gonna put on a box.
Just in case.
Goodbye.
Bye bye.
Nice.
Stretch the...
Oh wait, no!
No!
I hate this room!
No, I hate this room.
Okay, I was thinking this was the one in the middle.
I hate this room!
I know I...
slightly remember where it is.
It's on the other side in one of those, like...
I have to...
Oh, I hate this room.
Oh, I hate this room!
Because it's such a pain in the butt...
The nerd, I think, is right underneath me.
But it's...
knowing when I'm safe to...
move.
Until then.
Which makes it...
Wait, where's the nerd?
Nothing here.
He sounds too close.
Where's the nerd?
Um...
Ryo, I don't need you to be a smartass, okay?
Yeah, I know I can...
drop down, okay?
It's still, you know...
If I don't know their patterns...
It's still...
This room is also still very annoying despite that.
And also...
I think...
I think that is right there, right?
Um...
I still don't know their walking patterns...
and stuff.
I still can't see them right now.
So...
Come on.
Please.
I
pressed triangle!
I love the picture of him...
just floating in the water.
Just like a dead fish.
Nothing here...
Okay, where is the nerd?
I cannot...
I cannot remember where it's at...
in this room.
Oh, this is the PSG.
I wasn't paying attention earlier.
What was all that...
grip strength for?
Where is it?
And there's so many guys in this room too.
Again, it just becomes so...
I can't remember if he...
does his little walky thing.
Nothing?
Nobody?
Look, he has to go all the way up...
and around...
I'm just gonna run.
Where is the nerd?
Oh, it's down there!
Oh, it was down there!
I knew it!
Back asleep.
And you too.
Damn it.
I almost got him.
There we go.
But now it's gonna be...
Where is your status report?
I'm really needy.
Why aren't you talking to me?
Why aren't you calling me anymore?
Why don't you message me anymore?
Status report...
Over.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, uh oh.
Where is your radio?
No, I don't wanna kill again!
Um, just run.
Just run for the nerd.
Run for the nerd.
Let's just speed run it.
Run for the nerd!
Okay.
And uh...
Sensor.
It's like...
Down over here?
I think...
It's somewhere...
Is it this one?
It was down there.
Shoot.
Yeah, I think it's the bottom.
I think it's one below me.
Wait, where do they come in from?
Am I...
I don't trust myself with dropping down though.
You know what?
YOLO.
Uh, hello?
Raiden?
Oh!
It was nothing.
All clear.
Is it this one?
I got it.
There was nothing wrong.
Everything is alright.
Yep.
This is Raiden.
Disposal of the C4 in Strut D is complete.
I hate this room.
Explosives were planted on the maintenance hatch.
Glad I slightly remembered where it was.
This is Plissken.
Do you read me, Pete?
Pete!
He's giving him nicknames.
I'm listening.
I checked out the bottom of Strut H for you, Pete.
Wait, what's this about?
I asked Plissken to look around.
Knowing Fat Man, I can't shake the feeling that all the bombs so far were just wrong.
So did you find anything?
Yeah, a hell of a lot of C4s packed into the bottom of the Strut.
Pete called it right.
Were these distractions?
I knew he had the real thing up his sleeve.
So all the other ones were dummies?
Dummies!
Oh, never mind.
They're real.
But the detonation wouldn't be enough to destroy the entire shell.
But the C4s Plissken found would inflict serious structural damage.
That's not the bad news either.
These are sensor proof.
What?
It's a new model, I guess.
But how did you find them then?
The whole thing is sealed tight to prevent vapor leak.
And there's no trace of that cologne signature.
Uh oh.
Pete, looks like he fooled you.
Yes.
But you managed to find the thing anyway.
With sheer luck.
Bombs that are invisible to the sensor?
He used R1.
Hidden R1.
You can't move fast enough.
He's right.
I can try the spray from a distance.
Hold on.
There's something not right about this one.
I can feel it.
Uh oh.
Well, Pete, should I come back and get you?
No.
There's no need.
Ryden, you have one left to go, correct?
Yes.
Except for those scentless ones.
How about you, Plissken?
I have two left.
Hey, Plissken, come on.
Pick it up.
Pick up the pace, buddy.
It'll have to be me.
I have the level 4 card that'll get me into shell 2 in any case.
You'll never make it.
Wait, what?
That bomb, five years ago...
I messed up.
Even with all my experience, I lost it.
And a church was lost in explosion.
All those kids playing nearby too.
These past five years, I've lived a lie.
Lied?
Yes.
I didn't lose my leg in the explosion.
Pete Stillman!
Peter Stillman!
You wanted people to feel sorry for you?!
After people died?!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
This guy is...
Peter!
Peter Stillman, you are ashamed.
I'm ashamed, I'm...
That hurts.
That hurts!
That's not fair!
Oh!
His crimes are also mine.
One of omission and arrogance.
Yeah.
No one should teach the skills I taught him without a clear conscience.
This is the only way I can defuse my own sins.
Mmm.
I get you, Pete.
That one's all yours.
You got it, Ryden?
Yep.
I understand.
Pete, I've taken care of guards and struts G and H.
Okay, good.
We won't have to deal with Fatman then.
I wouldn't recommend you go into any of the other struts.
I owe you one.
I'll get back to freezing the baby bombs then.
The baby bombs!
I'm on it.
I'll have the radio with me if you need to get in touch.
Just don't ask for peg-legged Peter.
He's gone for good.
Stop.
Why would you... Nobody was gonna say that.
Nobody was going to ask for peg-legged Peter, okay?
You weirdo.
The hell does defuse my own sins mean?
That's a good question.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
This guy walks away, right?
He walks away, right?
Oh my god.
Can you not?
I think I can take him from here.
I think the other guy's still asleep too.
So let's just run for it.
Super baby bomb-in method.
Am I on the right floor?
Is this the floor?
Yes.
Okey-dokey!
We made it!
Woo!
Oh, a gate.
Yeah, that's so funny!
It's so funny that there's a gate here.
Almost.
There we go.
How much?
OK.
I was going to say, how many bullets do I have?
I think I'm pretty good.
I keep stealing from these guys.
It would be funny if you kept stealing from guys that they would have no bullets left, you know?
I wish that was... You know, they think of everything in this game.
Why is me stealing their bullets not doing anything either?
They're pretty good.
Say it again.
They go get more?
I'm going to blow... Oh my gosh, I forgot this part is like so close to the guy.
Good thing he's blind.
Nothing here.
Yup.
I came from this way, right?
Why do the terrorists have tranks anyway?
That's also a good question.
Nothing here.
It's just this guy up here, isn't it?
What does he do?
You're not going to pee on me, are you?
I sure hope there's no one around here that will pee on me.
I'm not asking to get peed on right now, OK?
Did I... Are the ones that I got before still gone?
I wish I could get this guy.
Oh my God, I can't see where his aim...
Can you walk away?
Is he going to look back?
Okay.
Alright, I'm going to go next time.
I'm going to go next time.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine...
Oh!
I love when they yawn.
They're so cute.
Look at him go, his little dot.
His little dot self.
Walking away.
I love it.
Alright, let's...
Nice!
Thanks for the gift!
Alright guys, let's save real quick because we're about to enter a hell that I do not want to enter.
I wish to endure.
What can I do for you, Jack?
Rose, please get me out of this damn place!
I hate this one!
I hate this place!
I hate it!
I hate this hell!
Get me out of this hell, please!
Rose...
I can't believe it.
Stillman's prosthetic leg was all a big lie.
I know, what a crazy...
Don't be too hard on him, Rose.
But he's got no right to go around pretending he's got a prosthetic leg.
That hurts.
That's an insult to people who really can't walk.
Everyone's got their own reasons.
Sometimes you've got no choice but to lie.
Are you speaking from experience, Raiden?
I guess it is necessary sometimes.
Rose?
It's nothing.
Well, see ya.
What's up with this guy?
He's so aggressive.
It appears that Fat Man placed bombs within each of the struts.
Yeah.
Sorry, I keep calling because I don't want to miss anything, you know.
Don't want to close my eyes.
Don't want to miss a codec call that's fun.
I want to get all the information.
There's a huge load of C4s at the bottom of Strut H that won't show up on the radar.
The old man's right.
There's got to be the same thing in Shell 1.
Yeah.
Watch your back.
I'm watching.
What else you got to say, Plissken?
I just got a call from Pete.
He made it to Shell 2.
Wow.
Really?
Plissken.
I'll take good care of Pete.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Someone on staff is a Snake fanboy.
No seriously.
Call Plissken with the M9 equipped, I think.
That's a Tranquilizer gun with a sound suppressor.
Hit an enemy with that and it's good night.
Sleep tight.
The time in which the Tranquilizer takes effect depends on where the sound comes from.
Why did Raiden nod?
Where you hit your target.
If you want to knock somebody out with a single shot, aim carefully for vital spots like the head or heart.
Good night.
Sleep tight.
I think I've seen this modified gun before.
Yeah.
It looks like the same gun used by Solid Snake two years ago.
Following that terrorist incident, similar models were made and sold among the fans of his exploits.
The fans?
Me.
That's me.
I'm one of his fans.
That's an American military M9 modified for Tranquilizer bullets.
When the Tranquilizer bullets hit a target, the round uses the force of the impact to mix the drug, also producing a gas in the process.
The pressure of the gas drives a built-in piston that injects the target with a powerful anesthetic.
It's like firing a small hypodermic syringe.
This M9 is a Tranquilizer gun that knocks out the enemy.
It doesn't kill them.
Little fanboys with the M9!
Colonel, what do you have to say about that?
Raiden, leave the odorless C4 on Strut H to Stillman.
Your job is to dispose of the C4s left on Shell 1.
Locate every last one.
Okay.
I like Raiden's small little nod there.
He's like...
It's so cute.
Wait, I also want to call him with the box.
Hold on.
Let's call him in the box.
Hey, Plissken.
Plissken, how do you feel about this box?
The cardboard box that you have is ideal for fooling your enemies.
It's true.
It's a very important tool for infiltration missions.
Very important.
Really?
Of course.
I can't begin to count the number of agents whose lives were saved by a cardboard box.
You mean everyone's using them?
Look, I'm not exaggerating when I say the success of your mission hinges on how you use that cardboard box.
It's true.
But in the end, a cardboard box is only made of paper.
Yeah.
Handle it with care or it won't be of much use to you.
You know, I've lost a couple thanks to you.
What?
Nothing.
Forget it.
Treat your cardboard box with care.
Lost a couple what?
Take care of the box and it'll take care of you.
Don't think of it as just another box.
Couple boxes?
Because of me?
Treat it with love.
Don't be rough, okay?
This is how you know what kind of relationship you're going to get into with Plissken.
He's going to treat you with love.
He won't be rough with you.
What a weirdo.
What are you talking about?
Oh gosh.
I don't want to go in here, you guys.
I don't want to go in here.
I hate this place.
Oh, I hate this Tekken room.
I hate... I hate... I hate Strut F Warehouse.
I hate it.
You can do this?
Okay.
This place sucks!
I don't even... I don't remember where the...
Didn't someone come here?
I didn't destroy all the radios.
There was one that I didn't get.
I see he's even calling.
I... I don't know.
Actually, I feel like it's probably been long enough that the radios are reset.
Right?
I have to drop down from the second floor.
I know.
I know where to go for the bomb.
I just don't remember where the node is.
I hate this place.
It's over.
Why'd you kick me?
I forgot he walked over here.
I'll be honest.
I
hate this room.
I hate this room.
I hate this... I... I... I hate this room.
It sucks so much!
I think that's the guy.
Maybe he's the only one with a radio.
I wonder.
Do you like any room?
I don't mind most of them.
It's really this one that I hate.
Maybe if I just...
Maybe if I just wait it out.
This is what it's meant anymore.
This room or when she's one microsecond late to the stream.
Or us when she's one microsecond...
Nothing here.
The status report guide.
If they come to check on the guy and find nothing, they should stop bothering you.
It's on you if it's worth the hassle.
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh, he's shorter than I expected.
Please follow forwards.
Yes!
Oh, wait.
If I use my gun, they'll hear...
They'll hear it.
You can
break the radio with M9?
You can?
Am I getting one guide right now?
I don't know if I'm getting one.
I have no idea.
I don't think you can.
Because you can't take out the... you can't take out the... what's it called with them.
Hide his body where?
I'm not...
I'm not getting...
Oh my god.
Who's there?
Nobody.
I'm gonna get caught.
I'm gonna get caught hardcore.
Where's the nerd?
Just give me the nerd.
How did you
just respond?
I broke your thing!
Oh, here it is.
There it is.
I got it.
I broke it though!
Why?
How are you still calling?
Okay, now I'm gonna go grab his body.
Fast.
Grab his body.
And run, run, run, run, run in here.
Oh my god.
Are they gonna come in here?
They didn't, they didn't, they didn't come in.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
That was so close.
There we go.
And then I'm gonna hide in the box.
I'm just gonna box it.
I don't know if they'll come in here.
I don't know if I have time before they come in here.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got another box.
Did they leave?
That's it?
Oh, they did not leave.
They're leaving now?
There they go!
Yippee!
Oh wait.
Did they just replace him with somebody else?
But this guy doesn't come in here, right?
But I still have to get up there.
Or is that the guy...
Is that the guy on the second floor?
I can't remember.
You know what?
It's fine.
No...
I think that's the guy...
I can't tell actually.
Nothing here.
It looks like they replaced him.
Ooh.
That...
I mean...
Where's the...
Oh yes, here.
Right?
Don't forget the vent.
Yeah, I remembered it.
Your little secret tunnel.
But also you can see it on the...
You can see it pretty easily on the...
Is this the...
Which...
When is this?
Oh!
Big...
Big news!
Oh shit!
Oh shoot!
Wait, now if I take out their...
If I take out their bull...
Or their radios, will they notice?
If I shoot their behinds?
Oh my god.
Big...
Big news!
Where's the...
Is it under here?
Oh.
Yes!
Big news!
Will they notice if I...
If I shoot their little behinds?
HQ will still notice...
No they won't!
That's the point of shooting the...
The radio, isn't it?
Isn't that the point of shooting the radio?
I think this guy is right here.
Lethal mode activated.
I'm waiting for him to walk away.
Nothing here.
Oh!
This is a dead end!
Oh...
Oh my god.
Where the hell am I?
I need to get upstairs.
Nothing here.
How do I get upst... Okay, hold on.
I hate this room!
Formulating game plan.
Is that guy upstairs?
Oh.
Okay, there's... Okay.
Now there's a guy down here.
Okay.
That's why I'm so...
Sorry.
I was like, that's why I'm confused.
Because there's a guy.
Right there.
I forget that the upstairs also has...
I can't go in here, can I?
Upstairs has like a little hallway as well, you know what I mean?
Where is this guy anyway?
Oh no, now there's two of them!
Wait, no.
I think he's still upstairs.
There's so many guys in this room!
The guy would spot you with a broken radio.
Then you run away and you get a caution instead of an alert.
I did know that.
It's...
It's the...
If they're out and their radios are broken, then nobody ever comes.
Is what I'm trying to...
say.
Where is this guy?
Beep beep!
Are you coming downstairs?
Oh my goodness.
Just a box!
Oh my god, I'm in his way.
Oh no!
Why are you walking against the wall?
Why are you... Why are you walking against the wall?
No!
Run!
Oh my god.
Run, run, run!
Damn it!
What?
We made it!
Oh my gosh.
No alert.
We made it, baby.
Okay.
Um...
Ugh.
I just need to get over to that one area and drop down and defuse the bomb and we'll be good... ish.
And then I have to leave.
Oh...
God.
But I have my handy dandy... everything.
Oh.
I have my handy dandy.
Okay, this guy comes down.
Right?
Who's coming?
Someone's gonna come over here.
Maybe not.
Just kidding.
Who's coming over?
No?
Okay.
Oh, there he is.
I'm a coward, you guys.
I'm a coward.
Here he comes.
Don't...
Oh my gosh.
And then...
Don't notice him.
Yes.
Good, good, good.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, shoot.
Uh... You know what?
Oh!
No, I didn't mean to do that.
Sorry.
Um... Sorry, friend.
I'm just gonna go once this guy stops looking.
There we go.
FRIEND!
Here.
Here?
Right then.
Flip.
Drop.
In.
There we go.
Okay.
Woah!
Just in time too!
That guy was right there!
I don't care!
I just gave him a little love bite.
That's all.
I have the last C4 frozen.
There's nothing showing up on the sensor now.
Good work, Raiden.
Thank you.
You were way ahead of me, kid.
Come on, Plissken.
Get on my level.
How's your bomb, Peter?
It's a bomb, alright.
It's a bomb!
You think there's another one in Shell 1?
For sure.
Somewhere at the bottom of Strut A.
Yeah, we left him a souvenir.
Yeah, just a little bit of a love bite.
Shell 2 will be well on its way to destruction.
You mean that Shell 2 will actually sink?
Oh gosh.
Not immediately.
There'll still be five Struts left.
But if Shell 1 loses a Strut at the same time, it'll be a very different story.
Oh no!
The big Shell's structural integrity depends on a very exact balance.
I think Fatman did nothing wrong.
If both Shells lose a Strut each, the whole structure will tear itself apart under its own weight.
I think... you know, people say Solidus did nothing wrong.
I think also Fatman did nothing wrong.
It makes combined use of a neutron scintillator and a hydrogen bomb detector.
You brought that stuff with you?
Of course.
I made the calibrations while I was in the past.
I was making nuclear bombs.
I was making hydrogen bombs in the pantry.
He's cooking.
But the best I can do is a sound beacon.
Not the radar.
Sound?
The shorter the interval between beacons, the closer the target.
I get you.
There's another one in that pantry I was in.
You can go back and get it.
It's all yours, Rodney.
I'm going to study it some more and see if the freezing process will work.
Don't touch the other one until I say so.
Okay.
I'll stand by until you radio in.
Okay, I'm just going to hide here.
I'm in like a perfect spot.
You guys don't even understand.
Nobody's going to find me here.
Carry out an investigation immediately.
I'm just going to... I'm literally...
I'm box...
I'm amongst the boxes.
Nobody can find me here.
Nobody will find me here.
Oh my god, look how fast they go.
Nothing here.
Unable to locate the AWOL soldier.
Wait, what do you mean?
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, what?
Where did he go?
I need you to leave, please.
I need you to like...
Actually, where do I go?
Colonel, what do I do?
Raiden, go pick up the new sensor Stillman told you about.
The one that can detect odorless C4s.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Actually, you know what?
It's probably good that we did this one last then.
Because now we're like kind of...
We're kind of...
In a good spot.
We're not too far away.
Raiden, go pick up that sensor for odorless C4s.
Okay, okay, okay.
It should be in that room in Strut C where you found Pete.
Okay, everybody's telling me to go get the smelly detector.
Raiden, I've raided a sensor that's capable of detecting odorless C4s.
Okay, I get it.
I know.
In the Strut C pantry.
Fetch it.
I'm just waiting for this guy right here.
Then I'm gonna make a break for it.
Okay.
Get up there.
Up there.
Raiden, please.
Or is it here?
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
Oh my god.
You looked directly at me.
Okay, we're finally out of...
the F room.
F U.
F U room.
Where's the guy that's here?
Oh, there he is!
Wait, not the coolant!
Oh.
Oh, come on.
Dang
it.
That was close.
We'll get him.
We'll get this guy.
We'll get this little thing.
Oh.
They can do that?
It noticed him!
Asleep!
Oh my gosh, they're coming this way.
Uhhh.
I should've...
abandoned the box.
Abandoned box!
I didn't know you could do that.
Do you think they're gone?
Do you think I could go get it again?
Gaming.
That was amazing.
I just unequipped it at the exact correct time.
No, my box is gone!
Oh well.
Treat it with love.
It treated me with love.
That was... that was true.
I don't...
I will never game that hard ever again.
I think in my whole afterlife.
I think I will never game harder than I did in that moment.
Wait, was that the orange box?
No.
My orange box.
The orange.
It respawns in the parcel room?
Oh, okay.
Does it?
I hope so.
I mean, there's lots of boxes in there.
Gosh, all these guys having all their stupid radios.
Doing all their stupid talking.
Stop talking!
Just...
Everybody!
Everybody shut up!
Everybody's always talking so much.
Soldiers these days.
Everybody's... the guy is so needy.
He's just always waiting for...
How are you supposed to... How do you know that one person doesn't call in, you know?
It's just so needy.
So needy.
Okay.
Why are they so competent?
SMH.
That's what I'm saying.
Wait, why am I not...
Oh.
La la la la la.
Ah, HQ needy.
Oh,
come on!
But it was... Was it this thing that noticed the guy over there?
Like, I thought I saw a little tiny exclamation point come up.
Or am I... Am I...
crazy?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god, please.
I can't hit these things ever.
Please!
Is there a guy here?
Name Doko.
I'm going loco.
First try.
Oh, I forgot there's no one under you.
How this guy comes in, you know?
Don't mind me.
I'm peekaboo.
I'm doing a little peekaboo.
I'm paying tribute to my country.
Where is he?
Oh, he's not over here.
Is there anybody in here?
Hello?
Wow, it's huge!
Here we go.
I have sensor B.
Okay.
How's your invisible bomb?
I'm looking at it, but I'm keeping my distance.
Yeah, keep your distance.
I just got to the last strut, but there are a few enemy sentries I have to take care of.
Plissken, you're... Does it look bad, Peter?
He's probably... Plissken's just a novice, though.
Maybe.
It's an odd one.
I think.
The detonator hasn't been activated.
What?
But the sensors are live.
Which means... Which means?
This is Plissken.
I've located the last C4.
Oh, he's fast.
Is that it?
I'm about to freeze it.
I don't know.
Wait, Plissken!
Wait!
That was it!
What's going on?
The detonator just woke up.
It's counting down.
Oh my god!
The big ones were rigged to be activated when all the baby C4s went offline.
Righten, the one in shell one should be counting down, too.
Hurry!
What's the remaining time?
400 seconds.
400 seconds?
Righten, move!
Get to the bottom of Strut A now!
400 seconds?
Yeah!
I'm gonna save real quick.
Jack, you okay?
Girl, I don't think so.
Is she gonna talk to me?
400 seconds!
Baby C4s!
Baby babies!
Hang in there.
Thank you.
Okay, so where am I going?
Strut A?
Oh, jeez!
Ah!
Hahaha!
Just run for it, Righten!
Run for it!
Oh, that's the door.
Hahaha!
Run, run, run!
Run for it, Righten!
They're dumb.
They're stupid.
Bwee.
Bwee, bwee, bwee.
Eh?
Which way is A?
Oi.
It's where I came from before, right?
Oh yeah!
That's right!
It's this room.
Everybody's still asleep.
It's so good.
It's nice.
I was like...
I saw the guy on the radar.
That's why I was confused.
Um...
Bum, bum...
We don't have time to deal with you guys!
Come on!
Pick up the pace!
We're all going down!
I mean, I don't have time to grab a snack, though.
I think.
He actually left me a snack!
Yay!
Go!
We don't have time!
Wait, so where do I need to go?
To the bottom.
How do I get to the bottom?
Oh, I go upstairs, right?
And then...
I go upstairs to go downstairs.
I think.
Is this PS2, PS3, or Master Collection?
This is PS2!
I think I'm just gonna go for it.
There we go.
Hello?
What is it?
Her?
Oh.
Fatman?
A proximity trigger.
Microwave.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Hallway?
Microwave?
The seven-foot range.
What?
It's not a technique I taught him.
Neither was that multi-bomb booby trap.
Looks like he's far surpassed me as far as explosives technique goes.
As for the rest...
Pete, get the hell out of there!
Get the hell out of there!
What?
Wait, I didn't take that long!
Get away from Strut H as fast as you can.
You told me to go to A!
Keep your distance.
No.
Use the spray from as far away as possible.
Okay.
Me?
You can do it.
I know that.
I'm not so sure.
You got this, Raiden.
Do it.
I know you can.
Pete!
I'm not sure how I feel about that.
I have a feeling we might be fighting someone in there.
We're going all the way back to where we started.
Is it in here?
I don't know.
I
can't remember where it's at.
Please.
A man just died.
Where was it?
No.
Hold on.
I'm looking.
Oh, maybe I go through over here?
Is it over this way?
Yeah.
We got tons of time.
I think we're good.
And you were laughing.
Did you hear what he said?
It wasn't me.
It was Raiden.
Is it?
It's not in the water, right?
There.
Yeah, it was Raiden.
I don't know how I feel about that.
Oh, no.
Is it this one?
200 seconds!
Yeah!
Come on.
Is it in the locker?
Oh, no.
That literally turned...
I was like, no.
You cannot be even...
You cannot be any colder.
I don't remember where...
You guys, I don't remember where it's at.
Why can't it be smelly instead?
I'm gonna check the water.
I don't think it would...
How would I use the coolant in the water, though?
How do I dive?
Oh.
Go down.
Shoot.
I don't remember how to...
There we go.
Oh, I'm so close.
It's like right here.
I'm like so close.
Guys, I don't think it's the water.
Oh.
Sometimes you have to look in first person view.
Stillman, can I get a hint?
Oh, wait.
Colonel, Stillman is dead.
I know.
Pull yourself together.
She has not played this game before.
I can't.
I can't do this alone.
I can't remember the bomb locations.
I only remembered the one.
Oh, right.
Stillman is dead.
The one that was in the pool room.
There are no more explosive specialists.
That was the only one I remembered.
You're fine.
I won't let you die.
Rose.
All right, then.
Is sensor B equipped?
Yes.
See if it responds or not.
Jack, no matter what, you have to bring an end to this crisis.
Okay.
Thanks, Rose.
Oh.
And down.
And round.
Guys, I don't remember at all.
Where the hell is the bomb?
Is that it?
Wait.
No.
Blind mint?
Want a hint?
Yeah.
Maybe.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm trapped in this little tiny spot.
Wait.
Ah!
I see it.
How do I get to there, though?
Raiden.
Oh, shoot.
We actually only have 60 seconds.
Raiden.
Raiden, please.
Oh, it's not time to play fishies anymore.
Or we'll be swimming with the fishies.
Come on, Raiden.
Raiden.
Spray!
Yeah!
Whoo!
Colonel, I've neutralized the bomb.
Good work, Raiden.
Good job, Raiden.
Thank you.
That was a great loss for everyone.
200 seconds.
Plenty of time.
Any damage report on the explosion?
Seems that the duct for diverting the contaminated seawater was destroyed.
And the central section of Shell 2 is flooding.
Oh, my God.
No.
The explosions ignited the oil slick on the surface.
What about the toxins?
The toxins.
The chemicals stayed in containment.
Oh, good.
There's no immediate danger.
Is the big Shell stable?
Shell 1 was unaffected.
Every MGS fan would be very proud of you, Mint.
The price was high.
But the threat of the bomb is over now.
I don't know why I couldn't understand.
I don't remember any of the places for the bombs.
What's the next objective?
Rescue the president.
Get back to the upper level.
Roger that.
Oh, yeah.
The president.
I forgot about the president since we were so focused on the bombs.
Okay.
I hope I don't get ambushed down here.
That would be pretty bad.
What can I do for you, Jack?
Just saving.
Pres-a-who.
They could never.
They could never ambush me down here.
Yeah, they won't do that.
They won't do that.
Hang in there.
Thanks.
Rose, please.
Tell me everything.
Bryden.
I mean, Plissken, what are you doing?
I'm so used to just saying, Bryden.
Bryden.
Hello?
Rose?
Bryden.
Dang.
The terrorists have retaliated for our bomb neutralization.
Wait.
What do you mean?
What?
A hostage has been killed.
Shot in the head.
They shot one of them on the roof just to make sure we caught it.
One of our satellites caught it clear as day.
Oh, my God.
Damn.
They announced they would kill one every hour from now on.
That's not fair.
What are my orders?
What should I do?
Stay with your mission objective.
Rescue the president.
Someone got shot and he goes, that hurts.
President Johnson is your first priority.
President Johnson.
My first priority.
My butt.
They're all in danger.
Yeah.
Jack, be reasonable.
I know what you're feeling, but you can't save them all.
No.
Not by myself.
Are you expecting that Plissken to come through?
Well.
Looks like he's turned his radio off too.
Jack, be reasonable.
No.
I can't complete this mission by myself.
That man was not included in the simulation.
He is not a factor in this mission.
What do you mean by that, Colonel?
Yeah.
Your mission must remain a solo effort.
What about the seals?
No second attempt.
What do you mean by that?
We haven't even gotten to planning that.
All we can do is wait.
Who the heck do you think you are?
In the meantime, you're our only hope.
I understand.
Raiden, go and rescue the President.
What are you talking about?
You can start off by getting to the upper level of Strut A.
Yeah.
Strut A.
You guys have to go to the bathroom.
I think this might be a good time to go.
Let's take a potty break real quick.
Let's do a quick potty break.
I think this might be a good time to go.
And then we'll go up.
I think right here, right before I go into the next room is a good spot.
I've got to go to the little ghost's room.
Potty break for everybody.
Stretch.
Get some water.
And go to the bathroom.
I don't want a pee buff right now.
I know going to the bathroom will be a debuff for me, but...
You know, I just gotta do what I gotta do.
I really gotta go.
Okay, I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Matara's out here trying to be like she's some Metal Gear expert.
Girl, get past literally two games.
She's on Twitter.
Someone was just like, there were games before Metal Gear Solid.
And she's just like, yeah, but they're old and janky.
I got recommended to do solids if you're really...
And then if you really love them, dive into Metal Gear 1 and 2.
I'm like, how dare you say that about Running Man?
I love that guy.
He's not old and janky.
How dare you say that?
Do you have a good pee?
Yeah, I saw that tweet and I was like...
Running Man!
I love Running Man.
How could you say that about him?
She's just like...
I like how someone's like, this isn't Mint.
What's going on here?
Mint has Mata's Twitter details.
Mata, I feel your girlfriend's tastes are roving off on you.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Let's not...
Let's not jump to any titles now.
How dare you say that about Running Man?
Running Man's the best.
Yeah.
Girlfriend with a space.
Oh!
Yeah, yeah.
We are girls.
We are friends.
Well, kinda.
That's...
Even that needs like a little bit of a...
I don't know.
Even that needs a bit of a...
an asterisk, you know?
Cliff...
Or a footnote, I believe.
Anyway.
Let's get going.
That's my ride!
Oh!
Oh, oh!
Oh, yeah!
Delivery!
Oh my gosh.
We get a hot lady delivery.
I don't remember.
I think you just wait this fight out, right?
I don't remember exactly.
Look at all them bugs.
Nice.
I can't tell you how happy I am that you rely back at all.
I knew this moment would come.
Oh!
Show yourself and finish me.
Are you obsessed with me or something?
Like you finished off my father.
Hey!
What?
Oh!
Oh, crap.
It's just Raiden's slightly nasally voice that just makes him sound so nerdy.
That's not him.
Oh, crap.
This could be interesting.
You've seen the fires of hell, haven't you?
Ugh.
Oh!
Hey!
That's my ride!
I'm so excited!
Oh, crap.
Aw, crap.
Might be you can give me death.
My name is Fortune.
Lucky in war and nothing else.
Fortune!
And without a death to call my own.
Hurry!
Kill me.
Please!
She's so awesome.
Oh my gosh!
Wait.
Oh my god!
Aah!
Te-te-te -te -te.
Te-te-te-te -te.
Te -te -te-te -te.
Te-te-te-te -te -te.
Te-te-te-te This is our first time here in Yandel's Dead Cell!
Why are you on fire?
I just have to wait this one out, don't I?
Oh my God.
Yeah, yeah.
I can't see anything.
I can't see where she's aiming at.
Oh my God.
I don't know how long I need to last for.
Raiden!
Oh no!
My box!
Don't go out of the... Don't get on fire.
Oh my God, no.
Oh my God, Raiden!
Oh God, Raiden!
Nice save, nice save.
Yeah, let's call it Kodak.
I can't hit her!
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
No, it came back down!
Okay.
Yeah!
Evade her!
I wish I could lead her to, like...
Come over here.
Plissken!
No!
Oh my God.
Oh!
Am I not on fire?
Oh my God.
Good boy.
Um, now's not the time, Cardo!
She's right in front of me!
Um...
She's right in front of me.
Isn't she?
She's right.
Peta!
Oh, seven frames.
I know, right?
Okay.
Oh my God.
I have to go all the way back over there.
So annoying.
He didn't say.
Perfect timing actually.
No bisexual!
No, keep playing the theme!
That is not where you ended up, Raiden.
Oooh.
Batman did nothing wrong.
She's so awesome.
Nah.
Hey, I'm right here!
You know.
I can still hear you.
Hey!
Yeah.
Come on.
Yes, queen!
Now!
Nice one, Raiden!
Nice one!
Yeah!
Baby!
Now!
Oh crap!
She's so cool.
She's like, not even you can kill me after my lover's been killed.
Raiden is a toad.
What do you mean by that?
Fortunately, he got shot in the head.
No.
That death was meant for me.
Aww.
Why am I the only one that can't die?
Alone again?
Cheated out of death again?
How long will you force me to live?
How much longer, dad?
You've punished me enough.
Just, just walk.
Just...
Shut up.
I'm not dead.
Oh!
Raiden, come on.
Read the room.
Raiden, read the room!
Come on, man.
Just like you'll ever, just...
But you couldn't kill me either.
No.
Just, just get out of here.
Yeah.
Just go.
Just come on.
There we go.
I can't read the air.
We are back!
Alrighty, we got to get all the way over there in 400 seconds, baby!
He's still alive!
You know that meme that's just like killing postponed?
That's him.
How is he alive?
Come on, Vamp!
400 seconds.
To the heliport.
Raiden has terrible luck with women.
It's true.
Okay.
Colonel!
Where's the heliport?
The clock is ticking, Raiden.
Get to the heliport on the roof of Strut E.
Strut E!
Is that the one that had the stinky plane?
Bomb!
Wait, why can't I go over to that one?
Hello?
There we go.
There it is!
Bomb!
Okay.
We just got to go through the hell...
Through hell F.
Just got to go through F.
We just got to go through F.
I just got to run for it.
Just got to run for it.
B for bomb.
Rude!
Fat man!
Oh god.
I know I don't have that much time.
But maybe I can find a snack.
No...
It's like the guards left and everyone is like, yeah, this will take care of it.
Oh wait.
I should be on the other side.
Hold on.
Let's go to the other side.
We call them fluffy people now.
Okay.
Did you already...
Oh.
I saw that.
Did you already defeat Batman?
On my way to do so.
On my way.
Wait a second.
Whoa.
Wait.
This is new.
You're not supposed to be here.
Why are there more guys here now?
Wait.
What the hell?
Why are there more guys here now?
You're not supposed to be here.
Oh shoot.
What?
There we go.
Okay.
Crisis averted.
Anyway.
Let's go.
That was a close one, wasn't it?
Anyone else here?
Nothing here.
I think I should go from up top.
I'm not going to lie.
Nice.
Nothing here.
I'm just going to take them out and go.
No,
don't.
There.
Oh shoot.
Clean.
A little...
A little struggle.
Almost triggered the endless guard.
I know.
I don't...
Oh, he is up there.
I was going to say, I don't see the guy up there.
Hey!
That's where Fat Man is.
That's his spot.
Why are you up there with him?
I'm just grabbing them real quick so I don't forget.
About them later.
Boom.
Okay.
Got all them birds.
Upsy daisy.
All right.
Here we go.
Look at all those chickens.
Let's save real quick.
Not that I really need to, I think, but...
Jack?
Yeah.
Rose, please.
My code name.
Rose.
Rose, please.
Everybody is going to know my name is Jack.
Please.
I like Fat Man's fight though.
I think it's kind of fun.
Be careful, Jack.
Thank you.
Oh.
There he is.
I think we're okay.
Maybe.
Actually, I'm just going to box it.
I need to get my old box back.
I need to get my box back.
Box one.
Box two.
Box one, where are you?
Maybe it's in the next one.
She doesn't need his code name.
All she needs is for him to remember what's special about the date.
Here we go.
Oh, there it is.
Easy peasy.
Right there in the middle.
Well, we got time.
We have time to explore a little bit.
Right there.
Totally doesn't look like a trap or anything.
We got time.
Not at all, not at all, not at all.
Looks totally not suspicious.
Nah.
Censor A.
Stinky.
Stinkiest area.
Sega, nice.
Stank.
Febreze!
See how close he can get to one second?
What was my time?
Oh my god.
You were briefed on this, Raiden.
I love Batman.
He's such a freak.
He's so eccentric, I love him.
Yeah!
All the time with every moment of their existence and nothing else announces its own end with such a fanfare.
Glad you could make it.
This little straw.
Oh yeah.
Yum.
Good year.
Let's drink to Stillman, shall we?
Oof.
If you destroy the big shell, you'll never collect your ransom.
I don't care about that.
What are you talking about?
Yum.
Thirty billion dollars in cash.
Oh, he's laughing.
So that's what's going on, huh?
What the hell are you talking about?
What the hell?
Oh, you'll know soon enough.
Cool.
And I could care less what they plan to do.
My ambitions are much more simple.
To be the most famous bomber of them all.
You're nuts.
No one's going to give a damn about you.
Oh yes, they will.
I'll go down in history, as the man who beat Peter Stillman.
Ah, yeah.
That's the only reason I assisted them.
Like hell you beat Stillman.
He had your number.
What did you say?
You have nothing of his courage.
They keep talking over each other.
It's so funny.
That croc died a dishonorable death six months ago.
Six months ago.
The liquidation of Dead Cell.
Call it what you want.
Only the right stuff survive that hell.
Set me free, you know.
Open the way to a new dimension.
Dimension.
So that I can become the emperor among detonation devotees.
You're nothing but a common criminal and that's the only way people will ever remember you.
A new dimension.
That's why I dislike boorish military types.
It's time to start the party.
Yeah, the party.
This is how it works.
I plant a bomb.
And it'll explode soon after that.
Okay.
If you prefer to stay in one piece, you'll have to decide...
Laugh and grow fat.
Yeah!
He said the thing!
Laugh and grow fat!
Hey,
don't shoot me, man.
Don't shoot me.
I'm not ready yet.
Is that all of them?
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I saw that.
Two!
Your favorite.
I literally just disarmed the other two.
Oh my god.
I just disarmed the other two.
Come on.
Okay.
Um...
Oh, I gotta get his head.
There we go.
I'm pulling a short piece.
What's up?
Where is it?
Dou, dou.
Don't shoot the bird, man.
Dou!
The way he falls.
I was wondering if I should do a, uh...
Oh, oh.
A uh...
Oh
my god.
What's the word?
Passive this run, I guess.
With the tranquilizer, but...
I think it's okay.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Maybe I should use auto-aim.
Are you gonna plant anymore or are you done?
Are you okay?
Are you okay, man?
Are you clo- Oh, one.
I got it.
More bombs!
You asked for it.
Where did he put the other one?
Oh, okay.
Wait, where is it?
That's the one I disarmed before.
It's not underneath, is it?
I'm right here, dummy!
Wait, where is it?
It's not this one.
Right?
This is the one I disarmed before.
Is this it?
Again?
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god!
Where?
Oh, here it is!
Hey, where did you go?
My bad.
Hey.
Hey, hey, hey.
Calm down.
There we go.
He's aggroed!
Oh, I need to reload.
Does that reload again?
Like in the original?
Un-equipping and re-equipping?
I don't think it does, right?
Oh, it does?
Where is he?
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh, it dies.
Nice.
Good luck.
Thank you.
This fight is actually pretty fun.
Because it's like a...
More bombs!
Oh, come on Ryzen.
Get his head.
Oh, he's right there.
More bombs!
One?
Oh, one.
Here.
Two?
I know.
I'm getting on it.
He's watching me defuse it.
I'm doing it!
Oh my god.
I did your bombs.
Come on, Batman.
Where are you?
Come over this way.
There you are.
Where did you go?
That was so close.
I don't know where he is.
Just shoot, Ryden.
Oh my god.
He's doing sick...
He's doing sick flips and stuff.
He's doing tricks and stuff.
Oh, I got to reload.
Hold on.
There we go.
STOP!
Don't come after me!
Don't come after me like that is spooky.
Oh, shoot.
He's so everywhere.
I also got to reload.
Reload.
You're so fast!
I'm just gonna do that for now.
Just so we have, you know, a little bit of...
A little bit of buffer.
That's right.
That's what I thought.
There we go.
Reload.
Where'd you go?
Idiot.
Oh.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Please.
There we go.
When are we getting more bombs, Batman?
More bombs!
This time for more bombs!
When are we getting more bombs?
More bombs, Batman!
Oh.
Woah!
When are we getting more bombs, Batman?
Where are you?
I just need one more.
Time getting him down.
There we go.
Aww.
We didn't get more bombs.
First try.
Yeah!
This one's not so bad, honestly.
Because he's so, like, all over.
He doesn't aggro all the time.
Alright, Batman.
Oh no.
Batman!
It's just the wine.
The party!
Oh!
What's that?
Now I have nothing to wear to the party!
What is this?
I have beautiful hands.
Yeah, he does.
These delicate hands can craft works of art.
He puts on so much moisturizer on these hands.
Brian didn't grab his hands!
Feel how soft they are.
It's the switch for the biggest bomb of the entire place.
I've always wanted to hold fat man's hands.
No use.
Once it's activated, there's no stopping the count.
Where did you plant it?
Where is it?
Somewhere in this area.
Don't worry.
It's very close by.
Right where I can see ya.
Where is it?
Go ahead.
Shoot me.
I'm already dead.
No!
Damn!
Think you can find it?
When it goes off, it'll take the big shell with it.
Oh my god.
Tell me where I can find the bomb!
That's your problem.
Die.
Bring it on, I say.
They'll be happy too.
I die here and start my legend.
Too bad you won't be around to see the movies.
No!
Laugh and grow fat.
Yeah!
Fat man!
Laugh and grow fat.
Come here, buddy.
Come on, fat man.
Laugh and grow fat.
Where's the bomb, fat man?
Getting the Peter Stillman is so messed up.
Getting the Peter Stillman...
You're a monster.
Thank you!
Thanks for the pun treatment.
Fat man is one of my favorite boss fights.
He's like if Vulcan, Raven and Running Man had a weird baby.
It's true!
Um...
What?
Oh, I'm facing the wrong way.
It's like where'd it go?
Anyway, um...
That was easy.
Laugh and grow fat.
Good work, Raiden.
Looks like all the bombs are neutralized.
Where's the bomb, fat man?
Laugh and grow fat.
Colonel, fat man didn't seem to know about the ransom demands.
Yeah, how curious.
Intentionally kept in the dark, I'd say.
He seemed to be coming from a very different place from the other terrorists.
Hmm.
Raiden, a lot of hostages.
Our president included.
Are still in danger.
Keep your mind focused on protecting them.
President!
Johnson!
What are my orders?
We have no idea where he is.
You haven't been in the central core yet.
I suggest you start there.
What are my orders?
Wait, I have another call.
Want me to take it?
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Best to keep our presence unknown.
Okay.
Hello?
How you doing, kid?
Plissken, is everything alright?
I just killed fat man.
Looks like I was out cold for a while.
How did you manage to stay alive?
Had a little help from a friend.
What about the bomb?
Diffused.
And fat man, too.
That's good news.
Aw, fat man.
Plissken is just taking all sorts of naps, isn't he?
What?
If the big shell blows up, the explosion is expected to produce massive amounts of toxins.
Never heard anything about that.
Huh?
Looks like there's not much danger of that in any case.
But the central core is starting to flood.
It won't last much longer.
What about the president and the other hostages?
No!
They weren't in shell two.
They must be in shell one.
We need to get the hostages out of here now.
No!
It's too far from Manhattan for a swim.
What about the lifeboats?
There doesn't seem to be any.
What?
That doesn't seem up to code.
Gilberta!
Welcome to Mambooship, thank you!
Darn.
It'll take more than a single trip.
We'll have to come back.
Can you pilot a chopper?
No, but I brought a gearhead with me.
He's a good guy.
I'll introduce you later.
Plissken, I'm on the heliport right now.
But I don't see their harrier.
It's out somewhere.
The chances with a harrier after us are close to nothing.
True.
Do you know where the president is?
No.
That one's all yours.
The president is at the top of our rescue list.
These are our orders, Lt.
J.G.
Your orders, not mine.
Fab man.
He's heavy!
I can barely carry him for so long.
Come on, Fab man.
Come on.
Here we go.
He's ragdolling him around.
Where's his hands?
Can I take his skates?
Look at them hands.
Can I take his rollerblades?
Good night, sweet prince.
What else is around here?
Any snacks?
Not that I really need any.
We handle that pretty easily.
Any bullets?
Softly quiet.
Ryden's glutes are for show.
Not moving big weight, I guess.
I know, right?
This guy.
He's such a skinny weenie.
I fell on my chair.
Hold on.
The calm before the storm.
Oh my god!
It's a ninja!
Oh my god, it's an actual ninja.
Gray Fox!
I'm like you.
I have no name.
I ha- Are you Mr. X?
If you like.
What was that?
But come.
Let's get out of the open.
Follow me.
That's just- I mean- Mr. X has an accent.
Neither can I.
Gray Fox!
Just a messenger from a lalilulelo.
Lalilulelo?
I'm so sorry.
This is Silver, I think.
Safe from what?
Eavesdropping, of course.
Alright.
Why did you contact me?
I've been ordered to give you backup.
No.
Ordered by whom?
Speak!
Throat!
I'll decide whether I need to know.
You are not yet trusted to make such decisions.
What do you mean by that?
I'll tell you something you do need to know instead.
The current location of the president.
What?
I'll take that.
The person who knows the current location of the president.
Who is it?
A secret service agent named Ames.
Ames!
Secret service, huh?
Okay.
I'll be honest.
The first time I played this, I did not notice the accent even a little bit.
I'm sorry.
If you're within range, you should be able to communicate.
I did not notice their accent even a tiny bit.
There's no reason for me to believe any of this.
Do you understand that?
Of course.
But you also have no choice.
I think I was just so like, oh my gosh, Gray Fox!
Do you have any other leads?
Where are those hostages?
Hahaha.
You must be Ames.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
The hostages are being held in the B1 conference hall.
In the Shell 1 core.
You'll find Ames there.
What does he look like?
We don't know if it is indeed a he.
I've never met this person either.
How am I supposed to look for someone without even a description?
I like how they're just like, um, hello?
That could be a woman.
Ames has a pacemaker.
Do you expect me to walk up to these hostages and listen to every one of their heartbeats?
The sound is too minute to detect an amplifier.
You'd be captured immediately.
So what am I supposed to do?
Use the directional microphone.
There's one somewhere in the core.
Oh, in the core.
Okay.
We gotta go find...
Get the microphone.
Get to Ames.
Get to the president.
Easy peasy.
We got this.
Take this.
What's that?
This security panel will unlock all level 2 security doors.
Level 2!
It's called a pan guard.
It works together with your body's own electronic field.
Yeah, I have one.
Nice butt.
The door is more heavy than any other section of the big shell.
You'll get nowhere just like that.
Okay, what do you want me to do?
Try this instead.
One of the terrorists?
You want me to dress up like one of them?
The surveillance camera won't let you on the elevator without the right uniform.
Do you want me to disguise myself?
Oh my gosh.
Yay!
We'll be undetectable!
Your new outfit will work in some areas, not others.
Oh.
The uniform alone won't fool you neither.
Not everybody has the same outfit.
Why doesn't everybody have the same outfit?
But I saw them carrying an AN-94.
All men assigned to the core section carry AKs.
So without an AK-74, someone will see through me really quick.
You could take care of the weapon.
Hey, hey.
He's getting scared over flies.
You'll also have to pass a retinal scan to get into the conference room.
Not the retinal scan!
Biometrics.
Crap.
Oh, crap.
Deception is not an option here.
Okay.
Oh, crap.
I suggest you hurry.
I'm taking their eyes.
They have a nuclear weapon with them?
I am scooping them out.
Even with the president as hostage, this is an island, and they have no visible means of escape.
Even if they do have a nuke, the warhead is no good without an access code.
The security lockout can't be bypassed.
They don't need to.
They have the code.
What?
How I?
You saw it too, I believe.
The Navy man would have a handcuff.
Yeah?
Him, yeah.
The guy who's dead.
The other half of it is on the football, or the black case if you like.
Oh no!
The football!
And now they have it.
No!
How did they open it?
That guy had one job.
Why did they have to bring the football along?
To a decontamination plant of all places?
But they did have to.
Because, after all, the big shell is the farthest thing from a clean-up plant there is.
What?
Dead Cell didn't have to bring a nuke along with them.
Maybe.
It was right here to begin with.
Nothing in this affair is what it seems.
A cover-up.
But why?
For what?
For Metal Gear.
Metal Gear!
What?
Metal Gear?
The very same.
By the only capable vehicle, Shadow Moses came free.
This causes the R&D Center for its newest incarnation.
Oh my god.
What the hell is going on?
Ray is so cute.
Better ask James the rest.
Lowkey, welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
Metal Gear.
What's this for?
You might be glad you have it.
Keep the controller's vibration function on.
Oh, okay.
I have my controller's vibration...
What do I need a cell phone for?
I don't know.
Raiden's little gasp there.
Colonel, who was that man just now?
He's not one of ours.
No, we have no one like that in our unit.
Yeah, who the hell was that?
He said that the big shell was housing a new model of Metal Gear.
First I've heard of it.
Colonel, what are you not telling me?
I've been completely open with you, Raiden.
I don't know.
Colonel!
I don't know or everything I need to know.
I forgot you can zoom in.
Snap out of it, Raiden.
I'll have the Metal Gear rumor looked into.
You need to make contact with this Ames.
So you believe that ninja?
Since we have no leads on the president's current location, we have no other alternatives.
Right now, collect as much data as you can, including anything on Metal Gear.
Metal Gear.
Are those my orders?
Yes, they are.
Disguise yourself as an enemy soldier and infiltrate the Shell One core.
Where do you think you are?
Understood.
Okay.
Enhanced.
You believe that ninja but not Plissken?
What if Plissken is the ninja?
Plissken, do you read me?
He took over for Gray Fox.
I just ran into a guy decked out like a ninja.
A ninja?
Yeah.
Do you know anything about this?
Was it you?
No.
Can you trust that costumed freak?
Oh, it's definitely him.
But the colonel told me to follow the guy's instructions.
And like a good soldier, you'll do it, right?
I'll let you in on a little secret, kid.
The ninja that was publicized in the Shadow Moses incident no longer exists.
The guy you met has no connection whatsoever with the incident.
And how do you know that?
Because I do.
Just be careful who you trust, okay?
I'm not sure how I feel about that.
Hahaha.
Colonel!
You have some splaining to do.
Raiden, make contact with Ames and find out where the president is.
Okay.
Our information indicates that Ames is being held in the B1 level of Shell One's core.
Head for the core of Shell One.
Shell One's core has extremely tight security.
Impersonate an enemy personnel to infiltrate the section.
But I need the weapon.
For a proper disguise, select the enemy field uniform you receive from the ninja.
This will allow you to blend in.
But you still need one more thing.
The gun!
It will look suspicious if you're not carrying the standard equipment.
All personnel in the core are equipped with AK-74Us.
That's wrong.
I feel like I'm hearing more and more of these.
What's that supposed to mean?
That I've never heard before.
These are so funny.
That's wrong.
Ryden is such a little baby.
I love him so much.
That's wrong.
Okay.
We gotta go to the core.
Which let's just...
There's that guy right there.
Does he look this way?
I don't remember.
Let's just run for it.
Alright.
Let's go into the core.
Like a good soldier.
Safe armies.
Anybody here?
Nothing here.
Oh wait.
Not sensor A.
Mind D.
Um.
Oh my gosh.
There is something over there.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Where did it...
Where did that come from?
Aye aye.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Really?
Oh my gosh.
These little bastards.
Oh.
Come on.
Kill it.
There we go.
And one more.
I hate these guys.
Low ammo?
No.
Reload Raiden.
Oh wait.
Is that all I have left?
There's no way.
Oh shoot.
How do I have such few left?
Oh gosh.
I have to be really careful then.
How am I not hitting it though?
Um.
Fat man hit them all.
No!
You guys, I think I'm in trouble.
Chaff?
You're so right.
Thank you.
I forgot I could use the chaff on these.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Beep,
beep, beep, beep.
And here I gotta run for it.
Cause they all...
Yeah!
More guns!
No!
I need the AK first!
I need the AK first.
Where's my outfit?
There it is.
Okay.
Looking fancy.
There we go.
Oh, strut up for the AK!
Oh shoot, you're right.
Oh.
One second.
Got a minute, Jack?
No!
I don't!
I found some information on where Solid Snake is interred.
Great.
Shoot.
I've located the grave site.
And the body?
It's zoomed for DNA testing.
Do you have the results?
The right arm was missing, but there was no doubt that it was him.
That body belongs to Solid Snake.
Why was his arm missing?
So the head of the terrorist group must be...
An impostor.
An impostor?
You sound disappointed.
I guess I was kind of hoping to meet the legend in the flesh.
I get you.
But it looks like he's not behind this incident.
Raiden.
The President needs you, I think.
Disguise yourself as enemy personnel.
And infiltrate the core section.
Your priority is to contact Agent Ames.
Agent Ames?
Agent Ames...
Okay, I gotta leave.
Dang it.
I forgot that I need to get the AK.
Okay, we have keycard 2.
Woah, look at all them birds.
Oh my gosh, we have that guy up there.
I'll take him out.
Came for the old and janky, stayed for the cute ghost.
Yes.
How?
Okay.
Where is the best place to shoot these things?
Cause I feel like I'm all...
It's the little gun down here, right?
I'm gonna run out of bullets at this rate.
Ah!
It's lower?
The gun is one shot kill but it's fin...
Yeah, I know, it's like hard.
Now they're all here.
These little...
I hate these guys.
I'm gonna have to chaff again, clearly.
But I just wanted to see how to get through them.
I'm wondering if I should just...
Okay, wait.
How do I...
Oh gosh.
I didn't realize how far I was.
What's going on?
Raiden!
Aim for the top of the site, not the tip.
Okay, okay.
I'll try again.
Or rather, I'm not gonna try right now.
But I will try.
Okay, how do I...
get through this?
Oh, I think on the other side...
Okay, I know how to get through this.
Phew!
God!
Maybe I should just reload.
Nah, it's okay.
Okay.
Alright, Raiden.
Nice, nice, nice.
And now grip.
Time to grip, buddy.
We got that level 2 grip!
Oh yeah, we got that level 2 grip, baby!
We're gonna keep going and we're not gonna stop.
Oh, wait.
Oh gosh, wait.
The trap is going down way faster than I thought it would.
Wait, wait, wait.
Raiden, Raiden, we gotta...
Raiden, we gotta go.
Ah!
Let's go!
Oh my god, it's the guy!
It was the guy up there!
Um...
I think we're in trouble.
Everything's fine!
I didn't know he was standing right there.
Get outta here!
Yeah, return to your positions, dummies.
This game always gets me.
Should I just wait out the caution before I go in there?
I do have stun grenades.
Okay.
Question...
Is the AK...
on the top floor or the bottom floor?
On the top floor or the bottom floor?
You guys wanna...
Well, you know...
If you guys wanna help out a little bit...
The bottom...
Bottom... The bottom...
The bottom?
If I die here, I'm just gonna reload the save.
I'm gonna go to the main venue.
And reload!
Oh my god.
Okay.
The button.
Nothing here.
Which way do you go?
Up or down?
We're dancing?
Don't turn around.
Keep going.
Oh!
Uh...
Is this it?
Yes.
I got it.
We're good.
Don't... dang it.
We're fine.
Where's the AK?
Let's get the AK first.
Where is it?
Where's the AK?
Are you kidding me?
Get out of here.
Who said you could come in here?
God.
Where's the AK?
Oh, there it is.
Yippee!
I could have... I was like...
I just hovered... I was just under the radar.
An AK.
I can!
Guards in Shell 1's core are armed with AK rifles.
Why is it like that?
Others are armed with the AN-94.
What?
The official rifle of the Russian Army.
Yeah, but what if I... what if I'm just taking a walk?
If you hope to disguise yourself as the enemy...
I'm just taking a walk from the... from the... from the core.
You don't want to be carrying an AK outside of Shell 1's core.
Who cares if I have one or not?
Who cares?
Oh, more bullets.
Oh, delicious.
Yum yum yum.
Get the M4 first.
Okay.
They're just being all sorts of picky now.
No, let's not leave through there.
The enemy cares.
They care... they're just a little too anal about it, I think.
They're just a little too like...
Come on.
It's fine.
No, like it's whatever.
Okay, this guy...
It's gonna be a bit of a pain.
No!
Don't come over here!
Nothing here.
Hey!
But now the bridge is all messed up, isn't it?
Now the bridge is all messed up though.
This guy.
You bastard.
Oh!
We got a few more.
Oh my god.
How's your ammo looking?
Not great.
Not great, I'll be honest.
Okay, so aim for the...
What should I be aiming for?
Like lower here?
Like here?
Oh my god.
No!
I shot one!
Again!
Spray and pray with the AK.
Oh my god.
No, I didn't mean to do that.
Why did you have to move?
Right at that moment.
There we go.
Okay.
Where's the other one?
Oh.
My bullets.
Please.
Brydon.
Okay.
As long as that guy doesn't wake up.
I think we're okay though.
I think we're mostly okay.
Oh geez.
What a troublesome spot we're in, everybody.
A bit of an annoyance here.
A bit of a troublesome spot.
But it's okay.
We need more bullets.
I know.
We'll get them.
Somewhere.
They have to keep the...
If everybody in Shell 1 uses the bullets, then we also need to use the bullets.
Oh gosh.
I'm scared here.
I hope they don't spot me.
Fight.
Ah!
That sounded a little personal.
The way he's saying it.
The way Snake said that sounded personal.
And being just like...
Brydon!
Like...
Oh, first we gotta take out this guy.
At the tippy top.
There he is.
First we take out this guy.
Okay.
Now...
AK.
I think I can get it from here.
I'm like...
I can't aim lower.
So I'm not gonna try.
But...
This one's coming.
Nice.
And once this one goes away...
Thank you!
I like to think Brydon...
Is Wawa?
Wait, where'd it go?
Oh my god.
Oh!
That was so close!
Hold on.
Oh!
No!
I missed my shot.
It's okay.
I can take out this one though.
Oh!
Too high.
Nice.
And this one.
Don't...
Don't notice me, please.
Got him.
Okay!
I like to think Brydon isn't injured.
He's just floating there.
Embarrassed.
Like...
Damn.
I f'ed up.
Okay!
That was truly my thought process, yes.
Okay.
There we go.
I don't think he's dead either.
He really just looks like he's kind of... sad.
But it does look kind of like... pretty far, maybe.
You know?
I love having level 2 grip!
Grip.
Yay!
All right.
Let's get suited up, everybody!
NRAK!
Nice.
Here we go!
Get a grip!
So I just have to not run into these folks.
Don't be...
Suspicious.
Don't be suspicious.
Why this camera angle?
Yes.
Don't be suspicious.
Where is the nerd?
I think it's downstairs in...
that one room.
Yup.
I'm just a soldier.
Yes.
Thank you.
There is the eye sensor.
To enter.
There it is.
Oh well.
This one is for this floor.
Oh shoot.
Wait.
Where is the other one?
Ryan do be like...
I do love the whiskey.
Or vodka.
Yup.
Don't be suspicious.
Eat that.
But not being... Oh.
Ryan.
Ryan in your uniform.
Hahaha.
Wait.
Where is it?
Oh.
There it is.
Don't be suspicious.
Not suspicious at all.
Wait.
Let's go back up.
And find the nerd there.
I'm going in the elevator.
I have very important business.
Yeah.
We gotta find the nerd.
And don't say the bottom right.
Two.
I didn't play MGS when it came out.
By any means.
So I was a bit surprised.
That apparently people were not that fond of Ryan.
And as a protagonist.
And it kind of reminded me of how people didn't like Gohan in DBZ.
Or Nero in DMC.
Kind of funny how that happens.
Right.
It is kind of funny how that happens.
Um.
Wait.
Don't be suspicious.
Where is the nerd?
Nerdy.
Nerd.
Nerding out.
I'm nerding out.
Where is the nerd?
There it is.
Don't forget to say nothing here.
Every five seconds.
Nothing here.
Did they come in here?
I don't think so.
Who is that?
Yeah.
I'll take that.
Ooh la la.
My weapon.
Oh my god.
There's a cat.
There's a little baby.
Whose locker is this?
Okay.
Let's go this way since there's less people.
But you come down here.
It makes me scared.
Don't be suspicious.
What's on B2?
I don't remember actually.
Uh.
B...
Remember what you're fighting for.
Remember who's waiting for you at home.
Second floor basement.
B2.
I like B1 though.
Wait.
Computer room.
Wait a second.
Or maybe...
Oh wait.
B2 I think is where...
I'm thinking of.
A certain friend is in here I think.
Maybe?
Wait.
Where am I?
No.
It is B1 isn't it?
It's...
Oh yeah.
Here we are.
What's up?
Venus and cancer.
Who's saying all that?
What's up?
Good morning.
Look at that bird.
Venus and cancer.
Please not!
Why is it showing me this guy?
Oh my god.
Can I help you?
Why are you running?
Why are you running after me?
Oh my god.
Why are we showing the guards fighting?
How?
They're distracted.
Time to go.
And take their stuff.
Oh.
They were distracted.
Oh shoot.
I got the D-mic.
Okay.
Top of locker.
Help.
You have the directional microphone.
According to our information, Ames has a pacemaker.
This should make his cardiac pattern fairly distinct.
Use the directional microphone to locate it.
Yes.
Okay.
Let me get out of here first.
I'm awfully scared.
Oh my gosh.
That was so close you guys.
Did you see how close that was?
I almost ran into them for real.
I'm trying to look in the locker.
But this guy is too fast.
He's way too fast.
I don't want to be suspicious or anything.
But I need some bullets.
Please.
Get out.
There's a mag...
Wait.
She said on top of the locker.
How do I get that?
But...
I need the M4 first.
How do I get that?
Woah.
This is just a little hiding spot.
How do I get it?
I don't remember.
Do I have to punch it?
But they'll see me punching it, right?
Wait until this guy turns around.
Woah.
Hey.
Can you like chill out?
Uh oh.
He's on his way again.
Wait.
Maybe I have time.
Oh.
I don't have time.
He's on my butt.
On the PS2?
Yeah.
Damn.
You know what?
It's fine.
I give up.
We got what we needed.
Crown guy is too scary.
He's too unpredictable.
Alrighty.
Good job guys!
Good job team!
The D-mic on the bird?
If I use it here...
Can I hear from... wait.
Where's my uniform?
There it is.
If I use it here...
Can I hear?
The bird?
I can hear the guy walking.
Rip nudie mag.
It's okay.
I have plenty of those already.
B1.
Alright.
This area is a little tricky.
Wait.
Hold on.
I gotta see his pattern real quick first.
Okay.
So he does have a second where he...
Um...
Okay.
And then he comes up.
Woah.
Why are you...
Why are you coming all the way over here?
Okay.
I think once he turns around...
I can get him though.
Wait.
Yeah.
What the?
There we go.
Alright.
Come here baby.
Come here little guy.
La la la la la la.
Come here.
Just gonna use your face.
For a second.
Oh he needs to be awake.
Okay.
I'll put him in the locker.
Next try.
He needs to...
Oh yeah.
Just open his eyes.
Use your fingers.
Just like...
Just like open his eyes.
You know?
Oh.
Wrong gun.
Next guy is gonna come out.
Right?
Like just use your...
Just pry his eyes open with your fingers.
It'll work.
Right?
Okay.
I'm so done with you.
Please.
Oh my gosh.
Let's see now.
Sorry I just had to...
Get rid of a...
Pesky fly.
Hello?
Hello fellow soldiers.
We're all fellow soldiers here.
We're all fellow soldiers.
I think I need to get that guy to come back out.
I think I need to...
Do this part again.
Need the M4.
Swap me like a fly.
No.
It's just people like...
Yelling at me at the game.
Like I get it.
Sorry if I forgot some certain parts of the game.
You know?
But like...
You don't need to go in all caps.
Being like...
You know?
It's okay.
Knocked.
Oh you're so right.
VTuber.
Why?
Why VTuber?
Oh my gosh.
I didn't realize this guy comes up here.
VTuber.
Why did you forget?
Why did you forget to do that?
VTuber.
Why do you have your weapon out?
Why don't you knock instead?
VTuber.
Okay.
Now...
Let's see.
Actually I'm going to Kodak.
Because I want to see what Plissken says.
No response!
Colonel?
I am!
Colonel you're so boring in this game.
It's like you're soulless.
I thought it was an actual fly.
I was going to say damn.
It should have been me who got slapped.
Yeah he's just so soulless.
What can I do for you Jack?
All he cares about is the mission.
It's like Shadow Moses changed him or something.
What happened to you Colonel?
Ignore the Alpers.
No Alping.
No!
I don't mind a little bit of Alping.
It's just when I'm like...
You know trying to remember stuff and people like yell at me about it.
Jack how's the mission going?
Oh fine.
Fine?
Is that it?
Look I really don't feel like talking about the mission.
At least with you.
I want to talk about something else.
Okay then.
Let's talk about you.
Yeah.
Your least favorite subject.
Oh yeah?
Then go ahead and say something.
Like what?
Anything.
Tell me something about yourself.
How self-centered.
I can't think of anything interesting to say.
Why do you want to talk about me so badly?
Because I'm curious.
But why?
Is it really that strange to want to know more about someone you love?
I'm self-centered.
You know sometimes I...
Such an egotistical woman.
Now we're talking about me not you.
Why won't you tell me anything?
Here you go again.
About what you were like as a child.
What kind of things you like to do.
Do you even like her Ryden?
I've never heard you talk about anything.
Oh my god.
I...
Don't you think it's just a little bit unusual?
That I don't know anything about my own boyfriend's past?
Rose, when I get back, I'll tell you everything.
Everything?
Is that a promise?
That's a death flag.
Right there.
Okay.
Alright.
If I die, I'm just gonna reload every time.
Okay.
I have to hold up this guy though.
I have to hold him up.
Okay.
This part's so annoying.
When he's in front of it, right?
Okay.
Um...
Can I... Do I use the AK or...
Can I use my gun?
There we go.
Okay.
Uh... Do it!
Do...
The thing.
Do... Oh.
I'm out of my uniform?
Do the thing!
Do it!
Uh...
Okay.
Oh.
Uh.
Whoops.
Come here.
Come here, you.
Use your eyes!
Your eyes!
Oh.
Uh.
Yeah,
I accidentally tranked him and it took effect.
It's okay.
We'll just go through it again.
No worries.
Coolant spray to wake him up.
But that's so rude!
That's so rude.
We almost had him.
Yeah, but that's okay.
We can get him again.
No problem.
Come on, man.
Come on.
There he comes.
Worst shift ever.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That scared me.
Freeze!
Oh!
Now I did it again!
Retinol pattern recognized.
You are cleared to enter.
You know what?
If it works, it works.
Whatever works, works.
Alright, we got our AK.
We're gonna be real sneaky here.
We're gonna look for AIMS.
We're gonna say, you must be AIMS.
You must be AIMS.
We got our directional mic.
We're coming down.
We're looking all sneaky and such.
Oh yeah.
You must be AIMS.
I'm gonna listen to half Johnny, half the conversation.
One of those hostages in there is AIMS.
I know.
The only thing we know is that AIMS wears a pacemaker.
Okay.
His heartbeat should sound different from other people's.
The music in here is so cool.
So use the directional microphone to locate him.
Once you recognize AIMS by his heartbeat, keep the microphone pointed toward him.
Then push the action button and call out to him.
You must be AIMS.
If it really is AIMS, he should respond in some way.
What if it's the wrong person?
The guards may get suspicious and come running instead.
I kind of want to see though.
I'll just have to do the room again, right?
I want to see actually.
Don't call out to a hostage with the action button until you're fairly sure that it's AIMS.
Well what happens if I do?
It'll be funny.
Switch the microphone for an AK.
And get out of there before a guard gets suspicious.
Okay.
If you're discovered inside, they'll cut off your retreat and call in the reinforcements.
You won't make it out of the room.
The mission will be over if you're discovered.
Don your disguise and look for AIMS while deflecting the enemy's suspicion.
I'm so not suspicious.
I feel like we're gonna hear that a lot.
I just want to walk around and check out these guys for a bit.
Can I walk on top of you?
Sorry.
Excuse me.
I'm grabbing stuff first.
The flag is on backwards!
I know there's patches to fix that.
The flag is on backwards.
Did you guys see that?
Oops.
Excuse me.
How many are there?
Two?
Two guys?
One guy?
Why?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Raiden?
What the hell?
This guy tripped me!
Where's my uniform?
Oh, here.
That guy tripped me!
What a jerk!
Your AIMS, aren't you?
They weren't suspicious.
Hey.
Why didn't you say anything?
Talk, man!
I'm trying to ask you if you're AIMS or not.
Come on.
Are you AIMS or not?
Say something!
Damn it!
Oh.
Hold on.
I want to talk to that lady.
I'm also supposed to be here.
Are you AIMS?
Your AIMS, aren't you?
I get so upset.
No.
Nothing.
Nothing, here.
I'm just like you.
No.
Nothing.
Anybody else do something interesting?
Where's Jennifer?
I don't know.
Jenny?
Is that... that's her right there.
I've been trying to get to her though.
I think.
This is her.
It's got to be her.
My name's Jennifer.
I don't know why it's so funny.
I knew it was him the whole time.
My name's Jennifer.
Aim your mic at her and click L3.
Wait, what?
I knew it was him the whole time.
Sherman?
Okay.
What happens if you do that though?
That must be Ames.
No, I actually remembered where he was.
But...
I... don't remember.
There's some things that I remember and some things that I don't about this game.
It's so funny.
Maybe because I really like this part.
No, I was sent in by the Lali Lule Lo.
Lali Lule Lo?
Uh oh.
Oh no!
You're here to find out where the president is.
They always are watching me!
It's always Ocelot.
Yeah.
Why are you acting like you don't know what that is, Raiden?
Come on.
Raiden!
Why do you act like you don't know what that is?
You'll never listen in on my thoughts, Ocelot.
I know.
Right here.
Do you really know where the president is?
Almost certainly.
He was moved to the first floor of Shell 2's core section.
The first floor?
The core of Shell 2?
Is he still there?
I don't know.
I can't get a response.
Uh oh.
You don't think he's been like the other hostages?
No!
A hostage was killed in retaliation after the SEAL 10 disaster.
Remember?
What are you talking about?
Wait, what?
Huh?
Did they lie about the hostage getting killed?
They won't touch the president.
What makes you so sure?
The case.
You mean the nuclear button they took?
Right.
And the case won't do a thing by itself.
That case may be the single most advanced example of a weapon's failsafe system.
How do you know that?
The password is nothing less than the physiological data of the U.S.
president.
Physiological data?
Raiden's learning words for the first time.
Heartbeat, brainwave pattern, blood pressure and so on are constantly monitored and relayed by his internal nanomachines.
This information along with the DNA pattern...
serve as a biometric password.
Unbreakable even by the latest parallel processor supercomputers.
The password entry itself cannot be performed unless brainwave patterns and heartbeats fall within normal parameters rendering chemical and other forms of coercion impractical.
In other words, the login must be made of the president's own free will.
So smart.
As a failsafe, the input must also be reconfirmed hourly, even after the initial login.
If a valid confirmation is not forthcoming, the system will automatically cancel the login.
And that's why they can't harm the president.
At least until the bird flies.
Is there really a new model of Metal Gear here?
Absolutely.
The Black Case serves as the launch key to Metal Gear as well.
Why would they hide Metal Gear in an offshore plant?
Haven't they told you anything?
This is getting... this is so much deja vu.
This is so much deja vu!
The oil spill, the tanker accident that caused...
The first solid snake isn't told anything.
The big shell was built specifically for the development of a new Metal Gear model.
The inspection tool was to check its progress.
What's going on around here?
I love riding so much.
He's such a weenie.
I can't...
Nose for eye too.
That's him?
Oh my god, he looks just like Dracula.
Use the microphone to listen in.
Okay.
I'm gonna be sneaky.
No.
That's Solid Snake.
You spelled it wrong.
Jeremy, you spelled it wrong.
Solid Snake.
Aw, dang it.
No.
King.
Fat man is dead.
It doesn't matter.
King.
He does the trouble of getting rid of him ourselves.
Why did he betray us?
To come all the way to New York just to get hit with a bell attack.
And his background rechecked just in case.
I'm sorry.
You think he was working for them?
We can't discount the possibility.
Especially with that intruder still at large.
Yes.
Yes, sir.
The man in the sneaking suit.
Yes.
You know more about those suits than I do.
But Foxhound was disbanded four years ago.
Because he's Solid Snake.
So he was.
What a block.
Oh.
This one's worse than that one up in Alaska.
That commander chick really reminds me of someone.
Who is she like again?
Oh.
He's thinking of her.
The circulation system for the contaminated water has been damaged.
The water being drawn in is overflowing.
And the lower block of the central section is flooded.
That commander chick.
He's thinking of Marilyn.
She's like her.
Now that's a time I'd like to forget.
Ridiculous that I had to get jacked.
I'm gonna go back for everything that was on me.
When I think about it.
That's when everything started to hit the skid.
That's a shame.
Up to that point I was steady cruising on the elite course.
Oh!
Here we go again.
Syntax and IR sensors are already in place.
Any effect on it?
No.
What about the present?
He's in there fighting for his life.
The password entry is on.
He's alive?
The black case.
Oh no.
One hour will need a confirmation from him.
His work is done.
Thank God.
No, no!
Yes, sir.
Oh, no!
The girl?
He's fighting his own battles.
Drugs?
Oh my god!
Look at him, he's daydreaming right there.
Still, that Russian crew is a pretty decent bunch.
Who is that cyborg ninja, Shalashaska?
I cannot even guess.
What about you?
Looked into.
Olga, don't cast suspicion where it isn't due.
Where it isn't due?
When you watched my father die and did nothing.
It's been two years ago, Olga.
Let it go.
I read the case file for Shadow Moses, by the way.
Olga, how could you suspect me?
I know that the ninja is not one of my men.
How meaningful you make that sound.
It's Sergei, we're still alive.
Let it go.
Olga, it's been two years.
It was just your dad.
Come on.
Sergei was my best friend.
If you sell us out, I'll kill you myself.
Look at them.
Listen, daughter of Sergei.
Don't ever let me see your gun pointed at me again.
If you wish, I'll put a bullet in your back instead.
I took you both in when no one else would.
You think any government would have you as irregulars in this political climate?
The worst kind of wet works, maybe.
But even that's doubtful.
I recommend against switching camps.
You've nowhere left to go.
Bye-bye.
The president's escort, guys.
Get on my nerves.
Whatever.
For now, just gotta hang in there.
You got this, daddy.
There's no paper.
It's happening again.
This damn right arm.
Liquid.
It's almost as if it's having its revenge.
How much do you think we spent on that arm and Leo?
The best transplant surgery team in the world.
I never trust a Frenchman.
Johnny, are you okay in there?
Oh.
There's something going on.
The incidents are becoming more frequent.
Maybe that man's presence.
What man?
I leave this place in your hands.
I have the intruder to take care of.
Yes, King.
I hope Johnny's okay.
Johnny's on his own battlefield.
It's true.
He must be Ames.
Is that really Solid Snake?
That's what he claims.
Johnny's fighting his own liquid right now.
See you.
Solid Snake did die.
But he's also here in the shell.
Makes no sense.
Either he survived or there are two of them.
What?
Two of them.
Yippee.
That's impossible.
Two of them.
I wish there were more Solid Snakes.
Anyway, what did you manage to catch?
They said password input was complete.
I thought so.
And then there was also this guy.
He was just...
Had to be made by the president willingly.
That's right.
Yes.
So this means the president is cooperating with them.
It would have to be, yes.
Why?
Probably tired of being a puppet.
But it wasn't a smart move to betray us.
Hmm.
The puppet?
We're running out of time.
They will fire a nuke.
You know what you need to do before then.
Fire the nuke?
But it's nowhere close to the ransom deadline.
Yeah.
Ransom.
Thirty billion dollars in cash.
Why does nobody know what this ransom is?
What are you battling about?
The nuclear strike is not a threat.
It's been the objective all along.
They plan to slaughter millions of people.
No.
A high altitude detonation.
You've heard of the Compton effect?
Total disruption of electronic equipment.
It's gonna be raining nuclear bits.
Caused by EMF.
The EMMA pulse.
Textbook answer.
Well, when an average nuclear warhead goes off within the atmosphere, the result is an electromagnetic pulse of up to 50 billion megawatts.
That's like calling Solid Snake King.
Oh boy.
And most electronic equipment will be toast in an instant.
If one of the key movers of world economy stops functioning, it could mean the beginning of a global depression.
No!
I'm already too depressed!
I can't be any more depressed.
Depressed please.
Pull it offline and turn it into some kind of a republic.
Hence, Sons of Liberty.
I suppose.
Sons of Liberty.
Damn!
Ocelot is coming.
I'm going offline.
I'm going offline!
Wrong movie.
They said the name of the game.
Sons of Liberty.
Search my pocket.
Hurry.
Oh, okay.
How do I know which pocket?
Oh, thanks!
You will be able to unlock doors of up to left.
Level 3 security.
Use it to get to Shell 2.
Okay.
Take care of the president before they launch the nuke.
He's on his way!
He's looking really sassy.
He's coming here.
Pick up your AK.
Stop yelling at me, Ames!
He's gonna hear you!
I got my AK.
Oh.
That was so fast.
That was it.
What do you think you're doing?
Nothing, sir.
I asked him to remove these.
I'm ill, you see.
I always knew that the DIA turned out second-rate liars.
What are you talking about?
No need for denials.
We know what you are, Colonel Ames.
You know what I am!
They knew that the president was planning to betray them.
So they sent you in to keep tabs on him.
Am I right?
A vampire.
You.
Sorry, Colonel.
You failed to carry out your duties.
You'll never escape the lalilulelo.
No!
The lalilulelo!
What the?
It's not IBS, is it?
Uh-oh.
You.
Which team are you with?
Show me your face.
You know who he is?
No.
He is not one of mine.
You know me.
What are you talking about?
Identify yourself.
Billy, we've gone way back.
Oh my gosh.
You're so beautiful.
You need it last.
The hair flip.
Get his arm!
Oh, not this time.
It's that ninja!
My name is Jennifer!
Hurry.
Get away.
Jennifer, are you okay?
You.
But you died.
Gray Fox.
Yeah!
Okay.
I'm getting out of here.
Yup.
Don't mind me.
I'm getting out.
Okay.
You can't have my other arm.
Wait.
Ah!
No!
Wake it up!
That's unfortunate.
However, we do at least know where the president is.
So there really is a new type of metal gear in this place?
Apparently.
No.
We're still looking into it.
I've also been told that the nuclear strike was what the terrorists were after from the start.
Not the 30 billion dollars.
I'm scared.
It was a cover-up all along.
Colonel, what are you keeping from me?
Yup.
You told me about the 30 billion.
It's not as though I'm told all the facts either.
Uh-huh.
I'm pulling in all the favors I can to look into all this.
Just be real patient.
This has happened.
This is all deja vu from Shadow Moses.
We can take it that they've completed the password entry and are preparing metal gear for nuclear strike.
No.
Get to the president as soon as possible.
But the president is cooperating with them.
According to Ames, yes.
Ames.
But it's also true that they're about to get rid of the president.
To Ames.
There's something else going on here.
And the president may be able to get rid of the president.
The president may be able to tell you what it is when you see him in person.
Once they get the confirmation for nuclear launch, they'll do it.
You need to rescue the president before then.
Okay.
Jack, I agree with the colonel.
You need to protect the president for now.
Protect the president.
All right.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I'm not ready.
I'm a box.
I'm just a box.
I
have the same...
Oh.
No, I don't.
I'm a box.
Where do I go from here, actually?
Colonel, where am I going?
To use the elevator, get in and stand in front of the panel on the left side.
I know how to use the elevator, Colonel.
When the panel appears, choose a floor and press the enter button.
And the elevator will start moving.
Rose, don't join in.
You can use the right analog stick to survey your surroundings.
I know.
Keep an eye out for approaching enemies.
Hello.
Oh no.
Where do I go?
Okay.
First floor of Shell 2's core.
Strut D.
Okay.
Also, Puskin?
Where are you?
Okay.
Strut D.
That way.
Do I have to go out through E then?
And then go to D?
Wait.
Was I able to make it there?
I'm trying to remember.
Do I have to go out this way?
Wait.
This BC connecting is broken.
Right?
And so I need to go to this way.
Yeah the other one is destroyed.
Okay so we just have to somehow get out of here without being noticed.
Just a box.
We just have to somehow get out of here without being noticed.
Oh.
Gosh.
Now there's other people coming too.
Get out of here.
Turn around.
I don't want your sass!
Okay.
I need you to go away.
There we go.
Perfect timing.
Awesome.
Not perfect timing.
Oh god.
Oh shit.
Nothing here.
Oh my god.
No way.
How?
Where's the guy that's supposed to be up there?
Oh shoot.
There he is.
I see him now.
Oh my goodness.
Wait.
I don't want to get caught.
Don't see me.
There he is.
Snipe him!
Snipe him from here!
Over a little... over a little...
There!
Damn.
Close.
He's... don't look.
Don't look mister.
It's okay.
Let's just... let's take these out first, right?
Yeah.
Who cares about that guy?
Oh.
It's on the other side.
Don't... don't shoot him.
No, no, no.
Just checked into my hotel.
Lali Lulee Long Beach.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Don't watch me at the hotel.
That's so funny.
Okay.
Can I get him now?
Oh.
Come on.
There we go.
See you guys.
I have a God aim.
Most of the time.
Oh.
God aim.
God... God... aim.
God... aim.
Yeah.
And one more.
This one's a little tricky.
He's a little fast.
He's a little furious.
Yeah!
Talking about baby!
Am I good over here or...
Are there more bombs?
Run, Raiden!
Just run!
We're good.
That was really cool.
Wait.
How am I supposed to get...
What's inside here?
Oh!
I know what's inside here.
The parcel room!
There's so many more guys, though.
Wait a second.
Wait.
Are they gonna come running this way?
They won't, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
We're good.
This way.
Oh, shoot!
It's level five!
Wait.
Okay.
Where's my Zone of the Enders box?
I want my own.
This section would be a lot cooler with a skateboard.
I think you're right.
Oh, wait.
Did I just go to this...
side here?
Leon falls asleep.
I might be...
a god gamer sometimes, you guys.
Oh, wait.
The sniper guy up here.
Oh, he'll leave eventually, though.
I think.
He leaves eventually.
Why did I not go to D again earlier?
Oh, wait.
I did go to D.
Because this is the...
This is the room with the...
I remember this room.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
Is he gonna come up?
I'm waiting for the other guy to leave, too.
Not gonna lie.
Yeah.
I'm waiting for the sniper guy to...
to take a nap or...
Take a...
Take a walk!
But there's this guy down here.
Will he hear me?
Does he come up...
the stairs?
Oh, he left.
Shoot.
There's two of them.
Bye.
Take a hike, bozo.
Ta-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Oh, my gosh.
It's this one over here, right?
Oh!
Hahaha.
I'm here.
I'm heading on over.
Oh.
Ah.
Oh, I need the sniper.
Aaaa!
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
Where have you been?
Checking around.
I'm in Strade H right now.
H?
Wait!
What if I went over to Strata H?
First floor.
Wait!
Did I?
I think I was too busy thinking of Johnny.
Take a look with your binoculars.
That's them.
Get a really good look at it.
I guess Raiden didn't ever set them off.
It was always Solid Snake that took them out first.
Do you need a PSG?
Wait!
Where do I get the PSG?
Plissken!
Don't try to shoot out control units with a handgun when the distance is too great.
The weapon doesn't have that kind of range.
Use the sniper rifle.
Where is it?
I saw a PSG-1 in the storage room on Strut F.
No.
There should be one left, so go and grab it.
I hate this game.
Let's just go.
Let's just leave.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Back to Strut F.
At least it's not so difficult.
Wait, where are we at?
E, F.
This is the one with our little sniper friend.
You.
You can't see me, eh?
There's two of them!
What are you doing up there?
Since when were there two of them?
The guy came strolling up as if I wouldn't even notice.
That's so funny.
Okay, here I go.
They're talking.
They're having a nice little conversation in the middle.
It did look like he was surrendering for a second.
Okay.
Oop.
Bucks.
So glad this guy is blind.
Nothing here.
Are you gonna look to the left?
Intruder to the left!
Intruder to the right!
At least getting through here is, like, so not bad, you know?
Hold on.
I don't wanna...
There we go.
Okay.
I just wanna...
Just to be on the...
Erring on the side of caution.
You can fast travel.
That's true.
Oh, yeah.
But...
I don't know what boxes I have.
Oh, to electric appliances.
Is that where I need to go?
Daily supplies.
Action figures?
Wait.
What does this one look like?
Oh.
Shoot.
I think all the things are gone, though.
It's just him.
Never mind.
I hear them.
They're not gone.
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
That was so close.
Holy cow.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Fingers.
There we go.
Okay.
I think I have to box it.
He does leave eventually, though.
Pretty sure.
Pretty sure he leaves eventually.
But I need to take these guys out first.
I do.
These dang ciphers.
Why is it always auto-aim to up?
Can you...
Right then.
Okay.
Let's go.
No!
Oh, shoot.
I'm actually in trouble now.
They won't come this way.
Ouch.
Down?
Down.
Goodbye, sweet cruel world.
You know what?
Sometimes it's just easier.
Oh, gosh.
I have to start all the way over here, though.
I'm so stupid.
I should have just killed myself from the beginning.
I'm going out on my own terms.
Oh, man.
I have to go all the way back, though, because I'm an idiot.
Oh, I should have just killed myself from the beginning.
Oh, these guys are still out.
Where's the entrance?
There it is.
Anyway...
They slept through the alert.
Nobody let them know!
Who?
Oh, that's the wrong thing.
Nothing
here...
Alright, we won't get caught this time, guys.
I'm just like, oh, this way is not so bad!
Whatever!
It's not so bad.
Thank you, thank you.
Are they all back?
Are all the things back?
Yup.
No, and I have to worry about this guy seeing it too!
He'll see it if I shoot it.
Well, only if he's looking in this direction.
I suppose.
So like, now.
He would see it.
Right?
No?
Why did you only see it before?
What?
I have a question.
Will they see...
I'm too nervous to go because the things will...
I think they'll see my box.
We heard the shots.
But...
That would make more sense.
If it was the shots he heard.
My D key...
D?
My square key is acting funky.
A little bit.
Did he leave?
Anyway.
Pressure sensitive issue?
I think so.
So...
Hmm...
Top floor?
Grenade launcher.
Top left room.
Middle right room.
Yes!
You didn't have to do that.
You didn't have to...
You didn't have to tell me where everything is.
You didn't have to tell me.
You didn't have to do that.
See?
I'm like pushing down on it but it's really...
It's giving me a hard time.
No!
It's not my fault!
My controller!
No!
My controller is fucking up!
Oh gosh.
No!
I'm really pushing down on it!
I am!
Oh!
My health!
It's been a while since I've, like, attached the ration.
Yeah, I'm bleeding out.
Oh!
That one was me.
Um...
Okay.
Alright.
We got this now.
I don't know why it's giving me such trouble all of a sudden.
But it is.
You know what?
I think I'm just gonna run for it, though.
After this guy leaves.
Nothing.
I forgot he looked this way.
This is the run!
GigaDuckMan!
You jinxed it!
You jinxed it.
Didn't anyone actually use the...
I think you use the bandage if you can't, like, lay down at the moment.
You know what I mean?
If you're just like, oh, I don't have a chance to...
To use...
You know what I mean?
Play more.
C4.
Um...
No...
More C4!
But no...
No PSG.
But there's lockers in here.
Hmm...
How fast does he turn around, this guy?
Too fast for me.
Oh, now I'm trapped here, too.
It feels like...
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
I'm scared to get him.
I'm trapped in this room!
No!
Where does he go?
Where is he, actually?
Okay, that guy goes upstairs.
Is he coming back?
This guy over here?
Huh?
Oh, here he is.
He's coming back.
Now he is.
My memory did not serve.
I trusted you!
One floor down?
Shoot.
Wait, no!
We already went in?
Is it the same room as before?
Or is it the one on the left?
I guess maybe then.
I'm just gonna box it.
Once he walks away.
No, not yet.
Maybe over here?
Ah!
RGB!
What the heck is this?
Wait.
Hello?
Are you gonna get up there?
There we go.
We're a gamer?
RGB.
Oh, the grenade launcher!
The thing you talked about.
Okay, so we do have to go downstairs.
Okay.
Raiden's gaming.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just gonna blow everybody up in here.
That would be kind of awesome though.
That would be kind of hardcore.
Not downstairs.
M4...
I see
it.
I see it.
What's in there?
Wait a second.
Can I shut this off?
Everybody shield your eyes!
It hurts.
Okay.
We got the M4.
And...
Assault rifle.
What have I put on their outfit?
Oh.
I don't have it anymore.
What have I put on their outfit?
Oh.
I'm still...
My face is showing.
What's in here?
What the?
It's ammo!
Why is this in here?
Why is there PSG ammo in the hole?
Is there PSG in here?
No.
M4 ammo.
Is it upstairs?
Still confused.
World's most secret ammo.
Actually though.
Nothing here.
Okay.
If there's nothing here, you can leave.
Now go up.
I
love being a box.
I love being a box.
I'm grabbing everything but what I need.
I'm literally grabbing everything but what I need right now.
There's PSG ammo everywhere!
It wasn't this room, right?
What was in here?
There's just nothing in here.
Oh wait.
There's a tunnel.
There is something here.
Hold on.
I swear if there's PSG ammo at the end of this, I'm going to scream.
Oh!
This is that way!
Wait.
Am I downstairs?
Don't look this way.
Am I downstairs now?
Interesting.
I think that's it!
Yippee!
Wait.
I'm still upstairs.
Where the hell am I?
Where am I?
Okay.
I'm going to go collect all that stuff though first.
Nothing here.
Wait.
I bet there's ammo in there.
Here I go.
I gotta go check.
What's this?
Oh!
Shut up!
We got a tranquilizer version!
Yo!
I had no idea that was here.
Nothing here.
My treasure is here.
Let's go!
We'll wait for this guy to leave.
I'm just going to go back around actually.
I'm just going to go back through here.
I know some of you might be saying, Why?
Because I also want to get that ammo.
But also...
Because...
I feel safer the other way.
That guy is below us.
Yeah.
Here.
Get that ammo.
There we go.
Don't come this way.
No one.
It's the enemy.
I need help.
I understand.
It's the first one.
Surround where I see.
While...
While the security...
While the caution goes down, I'm going to go grab some tea real quick.
What time is it?
Oh my gosh!
It's almost been five hours!
I have to stop soon though.
Well, I can maybe go shoot those bombs.
And then...
Maybe I'll shoot the bombs next time.
Holy cow!
Let's let this caution run out.
Like I said, I'm going to be right back.
I'm going to grab some tea.
You know what comes after the bombs.
I know!
That's why I'm like...
Maybe I will save the bombs for next time.
Because I think I don't want to get caught.
In um...
In whatever might happen.
Wink wink.
Wink.
We can save that special iconic scene for...
Next time I think.
Okay, BRB.
Are you in here with me?
Don't sniff that.
Come here.
Little girl.
You want to be in my chair?
No!
She got out of my chair.
I'm back.
Okay.
Anyway.
Nothing here.
Wasn't that so silly?
Everybody?
Wasn't that such a silly occurrence?
Oh my gosh.
That guy has hawk eyes.
That guy... I think he...
I think he saw what he shouldn't have seen.
That guy's vision is too good.
Gotta take him out.
Yeah, he is wall hacking for real.
Wait.
Does he turn around or...
No, he walks down.
Okay.
This is my chance.
We did it!
Yippee!
Those boxes you see from the vent?
The logo is McFarlane Toys.
Oh!
It is!
Yeah, I do know their figures are really ugly.
Affectionate.
There he is.
I think all the...
ciphers are gone.
So I think we're good.
They were okay at the moment.
They were...
They just have...
They just look...
They just...
Are we going for the bombs or not?
Oh!
You're right!
I'm going to go to there and I'm going to save at there.
So that...
When I start the game, we're right there.
You know what I mean?
So I'm gonna go there.
And we're gonna save.
Right outside the door.
Nothing here.
Right!
Oh, not yet.
Not right here.
We're gonna have to wait for this guy to take a nap again.
Our little...
Our little sniper man.
Oh wait, there's two of them there.
Oh yeah, I forgot that there's two of them.
We can wait for both of them to leave.
They'll go.
Sometime.
Some point...
There, he leaves.
I could...
They're stylized.
Did I miss fat man?
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Get out of here.
Go.
Stop staring.
Sorry, I know I could go and like...
Wait, this guy comes back.
Excuse me.
Take a hike.
No stretching.
On the job.
Gosh.
These guys are ridiculous.
They just act like there's nobody to worry about over here.
You know?
Okay, now we get through strut D.
What are you doing, Pies?
She's being a curious girl.
She's being a little curious cat.
As she does.
And through.
Okay.
Now I can save.
Shell one, shell two connecting.
Bridge, baby.
Let's talk to Plissken.
Don't try to shoot out control units with a handgun when the distance is too great.
Oh yeah, he told me this.
Thanks to the stream boss, but through.
Use the sniper rifle.
Use the PSG-1 to take out those control units.
Okay.
Right, and what you see there is a booby trap.
Colonel said booby.
The Semtex will detonate if the IR beam from the sensor is disturbed.
Whatever you do, don't touch the IR beam.
But there's no way to get through there without crossing the beam.
Good.
Neutralize all the control units for the IR sensor.
Those control units and the distance are obviously out of handgun range.
What do I do then?
Use the sniper rifle to take them out.
I got it.
Use the PSG-1 sniper rifle to shoot out control units that are farther away.
Booby was never part of the simulation.
Alright, Rose.
What can I do for you, Jack?
I'm just saving.
And then I'm gonna quit.
Gosh.
Already...
What?
Almost nine hours.
I'm so slow with this game.
Thank you guys for being patient with me.
Jack, I know you're probably doing fine, but don't get discouraged.
Remember, Lieutenant JG Plissken is with you too.
You'll be alright.
Salute to the solid mental.
Don't give me that.
Every time you say nothing, it's always something.
What's wrong?
You seem to think pretty highly of me.
Yeah, Plissken's the kind of guy you can really depend on, isn't he?
What?
Yeah, Plissken is one heck of a man, isn't he?
He's so cool, so confident.
What's up with this guy?
But he's nowhere near as cool as you.
He'll always be my number one.
What's up with this guy?
But that's not what I meant.
You know, you're kinda cute sometimes.
Bye, Jack.
She loves her tsundere boyfriend.
So next time, we'll take these out.
Wait, how do I use this again?
Zoom it up.
Sons of Liberty!
How do I see it, though?
Wait, if I crouch...
I wish I could crouch with the thing, you know?
That's it right there, isn't it?
And we have...
How many are there?
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Sons of Liberty!
I'm hoping that you would complete the game in under 30 minutes, but I think we're pretty close to that mark.
Yeah, we're so close.
No, I think I have...
I mean, I know I have quite a ways to go.
But that's okay.
This kind of game...
There's so much going on.
So I don't mind taking it a little bit more slowly.
238 is my record.
Holy cow.
But I get...
I feel like the more I play...
I mean, each time I play, like...
I haven't beat this game very many times.
And...
But I get a little bit more used to it.
Every time.
So, you know.
Happy I can catch a stream on my birthday!
Oh my gosh!
Jack!
Happy birthday!
Thank you for streaming my favorite game.
What's up, Jack?
What is that?
Flag?
It's the Sons of Liberty flag.
See?
Sons of Liberty!
I love that the flag in the other room...
is backwards.
And we gotta take out that guy too.
Little Cipher...
Am I wrong?
Or can he move the flag with the second controller?
I don't think you can.
Wait, with second control?
With a second controller?
If I plugged in a second controller right now...
I'd be able to control it?
Oh, sorry.
Good job, Jack.
I mean, Raiden.
My name is Raiden.
Code name Raiden.
I'm gonna go out with a bag!
I did save, right?
What can I do for you, Jack?
I did save...
Yeah.
What are you doing, little girl?
Why are you running all around?
She wanted into my room so bad.
Wonder if she'll say anything else, though.
Yes!
This is why I always try to save...
as much as possible in this game.
Yeah!
Because I'm curious.
More so than before.
Does it really bother you that much?
You don't want to say.
Like what?
You know, those things you don't want to say.
Those things you don't want to say?
Things you don't want to say.
Like that you've been married before?
That you're 80 years old?
That you used to be a woman?
What exactly is it you won't tell me?
Do you think I'd hate you if I knew?
Do you really have that little faith in me?
Pineapple on pizza?
No, it's nothing like that.
Then what is it?
Give it up already.
That's why his hair is white.
The fact that there's a side of you I don't know.
Sometimes I just can't help myself.
You've got me right now.
Isn't that enough?
No, it's not.
I'm sorry.
I know I'm being greedy but...
Nose.
She does not nose.
The size.
Rose!
This is a life or death situation out here.
While you're in your cushy little cozy room.
We are just in front of a monitor.
I am fighting for my life.
And you're not helping my mental situation.
Gosh, I love them.
Oh, I love...
I eat it up.
This one's for you, Rose.
Oh.
Use the first person view or the sniper scope to look around.
Colonel, please just let me kill myself.
What the
hell happened?
Right.
Right at...
Yay!
Now we can exit.
I tried to do a cool flip into the...
Oh well.
That one's for you, Rose.
Oh, my eyes!
Right.
Thank you guys for joining me for part two of MGS2.
Next time...
I don't know how far we'll get.
Maybe...
Two more streams?
I don't know, actually.
How much more do we have?
We have what's coming up in a second.
I won't be able to catch streams for a while.
Since I'm leaving on a European cruise.
Berlin!
I just want to wish you a happy anniversary.
Since I'm going to miss it.
Hope you have a great time.
Thank you!
I hope you have fun as well.
Oh, hold on.
I got to not do this because it gets my stream copyrighted.
It gets my stream copyrighted.
I hope you have a great time on your cruise.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah.
Thanks for the auto-soup.
I really appreciate it.
One of my favorite parts of this game.
Riding on a world-changing life or death mission.
This is the perfect time to talk about us.
I know.
It's so great.
Yeah.
What else do I have?
I'm trying to think of the order.
We do what's coming up next.
That is not Solid Snake.
Um...
We have...
The President.
Swimmy Swim Swim Time.
We have...
Another Sniper Time.
Naked?
Oh, no.
Wait.
I'm missing...
Oh, we have...
We have a guy.
That is...
I'm trying not to say names, you guys.
I'm trying not to say names.
Stop.
I'm trying to be spoiler free.
I skipped...
I skipped a...
Yes.
But, yes.
We have a...
We have a guy.
That is a little slippery.
Then we have...
Sniper Time.
Naked Time.
Then we have...
Crazy Time.
Let Her Rip Time.
Then we have...
Potentially you could finish next stream.
Now that I'm thinking about it, it's not as much as I thought it was.
Maybe if I like go a little bit longer and if I play well.
There's not as much as I thought that there was, actually.
I could still add a bunch to it.
Crazy Time is crazy!
I can't wait!
Depends on how long certain parts take.
So, 8 hours or so to go?
Doesn't seem so bad.
Probably do it...
Next week, I think.
Escort Hallway.
Don't worry.
I one-timed it last time.
I can do this.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me tonight!
I will be gone the next two days.
I will be streaming again on...
Sunday?
Monday?
I don't know.
I don't think I will be able to stream either.
But Tuesday I have stream.
And Wednesday is my anniversary!
Yippee!
So...
Next weekend is also quite busy.
Because I am attending another convention.
But I will...
fit in some streams when I can.
This convention has me quite busy, actually.
It's in Texas!
If you're in Texas and you want to come hang out with me.
I'll be doing a panel as well.
With Ayami-sensei.
Yeah.
I think every weekend up until...
a point is like a...
different event or convention.
It's kind of crazy for me.
But oh!
If also you're at MJS Con this weekend...
I will be...
There will be a little interview with me.
And you can also ask me some questions.
It's kind of a short little thing.
They have me for like a 15 minute slot.
I'm not like a guest or anything.
It's just like a short little...
How did you get into Metal Gear?
And then if anybody has some questions.
And things like that.
But you can see me at MJS Con!
And...
Can we drop off any gifts for you there?
I don't really have a way to accept gifts.
So...
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I'm sorry.
Um...
Yeah.
Time for P.O.
Box.
No, no.
Okay.
I'm gonna go to sleep.
And you guys...
Have a good night!
Have a good one!
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
For a fun time!
Bye bye!